GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
THIS IS NOT APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE I DON'T KNOW WHY
THERE'S SO MANY PEOPLE HERE
[inaudible]
OR SO.
ANYWAY GOOD MORNING THIS IS
SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR JUST TO MAKE
SURE EVERYBODY KNOWS.
OF WELCOME EVERYBODY.
WE WANT TO FIRST ESTABLISH THE
QUORUM.
THIS CALL THE ROLL SENATOR RAZA
HERE THERE NIELSEN HERE SOONER
AMBER [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- WE HAVE A REQUEST
TO REMOVE ITEMS ONE AND FIVE
FROM THE VOTE.
CALENDAR SO WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
THOSE -- TWO ITEMS FIRST AND
THEN MOVE ON TO THE REST OF THE
VOTE ONLY.
SO IF WE COULD HAVE THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SO WE COULD ADDRESS ISSUE ONE AN
ISSUE.
FIVE MAN TO IF WE CAN DO THIS
TOGETHER.
YES YES TOGETHER OF STATE
CONTROLLED DO. TO BOTH OF THEM
[inaudible]
THE MORNING.
WELCOME THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR I'M IN
NUMBERS MY NAME IS JENNIFER
URBAN AND I'M WITH THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE.
THE FIRST ISSUE -- IT IS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PAYROLL SYSTEM.
YES HE WAS REQUESTING SIX
PERMANENT POSITIONS AND FUNDING
TO SUPPORT DATA CONVERSION AN
INDEPENDENT VERIFICATION AND
VALIDATION CONSULTANT CONTRACTS.
TO CONTINUE EFFORTS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PAYROLL SYSTEM
PROJECT.
IS REQUESTED RESOURCES WILL
CONTINUE DEVELOPING MID EVEL
SOLUTION REQUIREMENTS.
AND WORKING THROUGH THE
REMAINING HOW DELIVERABLES WHICH
WILL DRIVE THE PROCESS OF
ASSESSING OPTIONS AND DESIGNING
A NEW STATEWIDE PAYROLL SYSTEM.
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THE LA YOU [inaudible]
I KNOW.
EVERY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
GOVERNOR'S MAYOR VISION PROPOSAL
SUPPORTS CONTROLLERS ONGOING
EFFORTS TOWARDS REPLACING THE
STATE.
IN THESE GO TO BOTH [inaudible]
EXCUSE ME.
WE BELIEVE IT WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
OKAY WE SHOULDN'T DO THE OTHER.
ISSUE. TWO FIVE ALSO.
I'M NOT THE SECOND ISSUE ARE
ISSUE FIVE IS -- THE CALENDAR
SPENDING THE ON AS YOU LEARNED
OF THIS ITEM -- AT THE SAME TIME
AS A LEGISLATURE WITH THE
RELEASE OF MAY REVISE LAST WEEK --
WE ARE UNCLEAR AS TO WHY THE
FUNDING APPROVED LAST YEAR FOR
CRITICAL FOR CRITICAL POINT IN
THE PROJECT WOULD BE REMOVED
FROM OUR BUDGET.
THE PROJECT TEAM IS CURRENTLY ON
SCHEDULE AS APPROVED BY CDT TO
WORK THROUGH A PROOF OF CONCEPT
IN. NINETEEN TWENTY FOR THE
SYSTEM INTEGRATOR WITHIN
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
REPLACEMENT SYSTEM ESTIMATED FOR
SEPTEMBER.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AS A REMINDER
IT IS CRITICAL THAT THE STATE
COMPLETE THE REPLACEMENT OF THE
EXISTING HOW LATER SYSTEM TIMELY.
DUE TO SYSTEM SECURITY AND
SUPPORT RISKS.
REMOVAL OF THE SEVEN HUNDRED
FOUR THOUSAND WOULD ELIMINATE.
THE RESOURCES TO PERFORM THIS
WORK AND SO SCO COULD NOT
CONTINUE THE PROJECT.
WE ABSENT A REPLACEMENT ARM WE
COULD RETURN IT TO THE MANUAL
PROCESS WHICH HAS A COST IMPACT
TO SCO CLAIM AUDITS AS WELL AS
THE DEPARTMENTS.
WILL HAVE TO MANUALLY ON IT THE
REIMBURSABLE RATES [inaudible]
FINANCE.
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
THE PROPOSAL IS.
AND BEING -- SO THE WITH WELL --
AS THE MARKET HAS BEEN UNDER WAY
AND INTERFACES.
OTHER ISSUES THIS WILL ALLOW --
AND TO COME BACK AND SO.
WE WE SEEM TO BE GETTING.
INFORMATION AND I REALIZE THIS
IS THE GROUP CONTROL IS ALL
ABOUT THE SPELL.
THIS CALL IS.
EVERYTHING'S GOING FINE.
INTEGRATIONS GOING FINE.
THE CONCERN OF MINE THAT.
YOU WANT TO PAUSE THE PROJECT.
IN ORDER TO GET THIS GUY OUT.
BASICALLY UP TO SPEED.
SEEMS TO ME THAT THESE.
PRESS DOES ALSO SOME OF THESE
ARE INDEPENDENT EFFORTS RIGHT
[inaudible]
AND I'M.
CONCERNED.
THAT WE'RE NOT ACCELERATING.
THE REVISION THE MODERNIZATION
STATES A ROLE SYSTEM.
I REMEMBER YEARS AGO THERE WAS
TALK ABOUT.
BACK THE SYSTEM WAS.
CREDIBLY ANTIQUATED OPERATING ON
KOBOL WE'RE YOU KNOW.
BRING BACK RETIRED A NEW AND
SOME ORDER TO BE ABLE TO HELP
THE SYSTEM FUNCTION AND SO ANY
DELAY.
PAUSES ME CONCERNED.
IF THE PAYROLL SYSTEM GOT A BIT.
IT'S NOT LIKE SYBIL THAT'S GOING.
TO INFLUENCE AN EMPTY OUR
ABILITY TO IMPLEMENT
[inaudible]
POLICY.
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER.
TWO SHOULD BREAK DOWN THE BEACH.
IT WORKS ALL AROUND THIS
BUILDING [inaudible]
SO.
IF YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON THOSE.
SO SURE AND JUST TO VERIFY THAT
THE MAYOR VISIONING FUNDING TO
CONTINUE.
AND FOR THOSE RESOURCES ARE
RECOMMENDED A PERMANENT REPORT
IS BUT ONE RIGHT.
AND THEN THERE'S THE OTHER PARTY
OR THE OTHER REIMBURSEMENT CLAIM
THAT ONE BECAUSE IT.
THE SEPARATE FUNCTION MAKING
SURE THAT INTEGRATE BASED ON THE
IN WITH OTHER INTERFACE.
WHAT IS CONTROL IS AUTISTIC?
BOX.
THIS GAL IN ANY WAY.
WHAT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
REFERENCED IS THE FUTURE
INTEGRATION BETWEEN THE FOR
APPROXIMATELY THREE YEARS?
AND WE HAVE THE STATE AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE APPROVED A
GREAT INVESTMENT TO GET US TO
THE POINT WHERE WE ARE.
THIS NEXT YEAR WOULD BE
CONDUCTING THE PROOF OF CONCEPT
WHICH WOULD.
DETERMINE WHICH BOB FORMED BEST
SERVES THE STATE SO IN NO WAY
ARE WE BUILDING INTERFACES
WITHIN THIS NEXT FISCAL YEAR.
SO THAT'S NOT A CONCERN OR AN
IMPACT IN ANY WAY ON THE
INTERFACES.
THAT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE WANTS
TO ENSURE GETS BUILT IN IS
STABLE IN THE FISCAL SYSTEMS.
THEIR RELATIONSHIP NO TOUCHING
IT AT THE END OF THIS YEAR.
AT THE END OF THIS COMING FISCAL
YEAR WE CONTINUE WITH THE
FUNDING WE WILL KNOW WHICH BOB
FORM WILL BEST SERVE THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND AT THAT FUTURE
TIME.
REQUIREMENTS WOULD THEN BE
WRITTEN AND DESIGNED FOR THE
INTERFACE BUT AGAIN THIS IS NOT
A RELATIONSHIP WITH HIS PROJECT
AT THIS TIME.
THIS CALL ASKED THAT IT IS THE
ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE THE SEVEN NOT MUCH SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS BE.
BASICALLY MOVED THE BUDGET.
LS BUT NO NO THAT THAT THIS IS
AN ADMINISTRATION.
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE BACK TO
THE RESPONSE?
WE WE FEEL THAT.
AT THIS POINT IN THE PROJECT
DEVELOPMENT WITHIN THE MARKET OF
PALATABLE LIFE PART OF LIFE.
IT IN THE ALTERNATIVE
DEVELOPMENT.
AND BEFORE IT GETS INTO THE
POLLUTION DEVELOPMENT AND
PROCUREMENT WE THINK THAT WE
SHOULD.
ALL THESE OTHER THINGS THEY'RE
GOING ON WITH.
THEY WILL ALL HAVE.
GET A LITTLE PART [inaudible]
WELL.
I DON'T FIND THAT CONVINCING.
THIS CAL IS A PROBLEM EVERYWHERE
WHICH KEEPS STUMBLING OVER.
AND IT'S BEEN AROUND FAR TOO
LONG. TO KEEP GIVING SLACK HERE
OR THERE.
IF WITH YOU THEY'LL BE SOME
OTHERS THAT HAVE SOME DIFFICULTY
THE MAN CHAIR I CANNOT GO ALONG
WITH IT.
THE LATE ALL [inaudible]
SO WHAT.
IN IN YOU'LL INDULGE MY BOTH
NEWNESS AND MAYBE IGNORANCE IS
IT SO THIS GIRL IS AN **** FOR
THIS CONTROL OFF.
NASA'S BUT THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
DISASTER.
SELECT IT THE ENTIRE BUDGET
PROPOSAL WELL AS WE'RE LOOKING
AT VARIOUS.
ITEMS GOING FORWARD WITH IT THIS
PIECE OF THAT.
IF THIS MOTION BE BODIES.
SO THE PROJECT IN THOSE EFFORTS.
OTHER AT THE PUMP.
OR OTHER MEANING YOU OTHER
INTEGRATED [inaudible]
THIS ITEM [inaudible]
THANK.
I GET THAT YOU WANT TO I'M I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE WE
WE HAVE THIS CALL.
BUT I BELIEVE BE SMART PEOPLE
THERE THAT ARE TECHNICALLY
PROFICIENT WITH THE PATROL IS
OFFICE.
CHARGE OF PAYROLL IS ALL
TOGETHER AND THAT'S MY WORK.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL I'LL ONLY
LOVE SOMEBODY SOMEBODY.
HE'S SAID THAT THEY SHOULD BE
PAUSE IN.
SO I'M I'M LISTENIN DEALS.
THAT THAT THAT.
IT'S NOT.
BOTH IT'S COMMONLY USED.
PHRASES COMMONLY USED TO WRITE.
SO IS IT THAT.
THE ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES THIS
FUNDING THAT WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
PUTTING IN WHERE INVESTING THE
FUNDING NEEDED.
WITH TE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE ON THE MOST IMPORTANT.
PROGRAM WERE THE MOST IMPORTANT
CHANGES LIKE THIS GIRL.
THIS IS A REALLY.
MALTESE I IMAGINE.
RIGHT.
A DRESS.
I'M I JUST WANNA [inaudible]
SO.
SO LOOKING AT THE TOTALITY OF IT
RIGHT THAT'S WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE
TO ME YOU'RE SAYING.
LET'S HOLD OFF ON THIS LET'S
CONTINUE WITH THE MOST IMPORTANT.
AND AND FOCUS ON THOSE WITH THIS
OFFER A BIT IT'S NOT GONNA.
THROW EVERYTHING OUT OF WHACK
RIGHT THE PROJECT WOULD NOT BE
AMPLE THAT WOULD JUST BE.
SO ANY EFFORT TO DATE WOULD BE
ARCHIVED.
WHEN WHEN?
THE REVIEW IT.
YES.
AND I'M SORRY CAN INTRODUCE
MYSELF REGIONALLY IN GENERAL AND
THE CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER.
OTHER STOCK THANK YOU.
AND HOUSING THE PROJECT RIGHT.
WOULD CAUSE AND EVERYTHING WE'VE
INVESTED IN AT THIS POINT IN
TIME TO BE WASTED THERE IS
NOTHING THAT SOUTH TO PULL UP TO
THIS POINT BECAUSE WE'VE NOT YET
AND ON SEPT.
ALL WE HAVE.
PLEADED WITH DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT.
IS THE PROCUREMENT METHODOLOGY
WE WILL USE TO DO THAT.
ON SET AND THE REASON THAT THE
PAS IS.
CRITICAL IN A VERY DAMAGING WAY
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
THE CURRENT LEADER SYSTEM.
WHICH PAYS OUT OVER SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN
TRAVEL REIMBURSEMENT CLAIMS.
CURRENTLY HAS THE BUILT IN
THRESHOLD TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
AREN'T EXPLOITING.
AND TRAVEL REIMBURSEMENT LIMITS
HOTEL LIMITS FOOD LIMITS.
IF THIS IS PAUSED OUR CALENDARS
SYSTEM IS CURRENTLY SET TO
EXPIRE BY IBM NEXT YEAR.
WE'VE ASKED FOR AN EXTENSION ON
THAT CONTRACT.
IF THEY KNOW THAT THIS IS PAUSED
THE COST OF THAT EXTENSION IS
GOING TO BE SKYROCKETING SO WE
WILL BE HELD AT A MUCH HIGHER.
THRESHOLD IF YOU WILL BY IBM.
TO COME UP WITH THE EXTENSION ON
THE CURRENT CONTRACT.
IF THE PROJECT.
IF OUR CURRENT CALENDAR SYSTEM
GOES DOWN WE HAVE TO RESORT TO
MANUALLY OUR OFFICE HAS SEEN.
I'M TRAVEL REIMBURSEMENT CLAIMS
THERE'S NO AUDIT THERE THAT
WOULD STOP PEOPLE FROM CLAIMING
MORE IN COUNTIES THEN THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO WERE ALREADY PAYING
OUT MORE THAN SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION.
AUDITING STAFF ALONE AT THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE WOULD MORE
THAN DOUBLE TO TRYING TO KEEP UP
WITH.
THE AUDITING OF TRAVEL EXPENSE
CLAIMS WHERE WE HAVE A SYSTEM
THAT DOES IT IN AN AUTOMATED
FASHION.
AND THE WORKLOAD ON THE
DEPARTMENTS IF WE WERE TO GO TO
A PAPER SYSTEM IS ENORMOUS RIGHT
NOW THIS IS AN ELECTRONIC SYSTEM
THAT HAS.
WORKED LOW ROUTING AND PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE.
TO IT TAKES YOU KNOW PAPER
AROUND FROM PERSON TO PERSON TO
PERSON TO GET THESE APPROVED AND
SO.
THE ADMINISTRATIVE IMPACT ON
PERMITS WOULD BE HUGE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE IMPACT. TO THE
STATE IS VERY LARGE AND WE HAVE
A SECURITY RISK.
THE SECURITY SYSTEM RIGHT NOW ON
THE CALENDARS IN THE REASON IBM
IS NO LONGER SUPPORTING IT.
IS BECAUSE THERE IS AN
EXPLOITABLE SECURITY RISK WITH
THIS PLATFORM.
AND IBM HAS SAID THIS IS NOT
THEIR INTENTION TO KEEP THIS
PRODUCT GOING AGAIN BECAUSE THIS.
IN THAT PAYS OUT SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS -- ANNUALLY MORE
THAN THAT.
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED THAT AS A
SECURITY RISK IN CYBER SECURITY
BEING ONE OF THE HIGHEST
CONCERNS OF THE LEGISLATURE.
WE DON'T WANT TO LEAVE A
VULNERABLE SYSTEM WITH OUT A
PLAN RIGHT NOW TO BE REPLACING
THAT TECHNOLOGY BEFORE IT FAILS.
AND AGAIN THE RESOURCES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY DIRECTED
TO THIS PRODUCT PROJECT.
ARE NOT IN ANY WAY RELATED. TO
THE RESOURCES SCO HAS BEEN
IMPROVED TO DEDICATE TOWARDS
THIS GAL OUR COMMITMENT TO
FISCAL REMAINS UNCHANGED THE
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE WORKING
ON THE SCALE.
REMAINED FULLY DEDICATED AND AND
CHANGE THEY ARE NOT THE SAME
RESOURCES THAT ARE WORKING ON A
LATER.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FOUR AND A
HALF HE WIPES OUT LATER.
YES.
YEAH I WOULD MOVE.
MISSION REQUEST I THINK THEY'VE
NOT MADE A COMPELLING ARGUMENT
HERE BUT IF YOU WANTED TO
CONTINUE.
OKAY SO WHERE.
THAT'S WITH REGARDS TO CAL
EIGHTERS.
THE TRAVEL NUMBER.
FIVE REJECT REJECT THAT THAT TO
DECREASE ANOTHER WAY REJECTED
DECREASED.
C. BUT THEN IT LOOKS LIKE IS IT.
I COULDN'T EVEN SAY IT'S ANY
SOUND AND FOUND -- WHICH I THINK
IS THIS BILL IS ALL THE WAY
COMPLETE ARE YOU SAY YOU HAVE AN
ESTABLISHED CONTRACT.
WITH IBM CORRECT [inaudible]
AND THIS WOULD BE AN ABROGATION
OF THAT PROVISION DONE THEY'RE
GOING TO WANT TO NEGOTIATE A
HIGHER.
RIGHT WE NEED AN EXTENSION -- TO
CONTINUE WITH THEM AND IT WOULD
BE OF LIMITED DURATION THE OZ
THE TERM OF THE HOUSE IS NOT
IDENTIFIED.
IF THE PAUSES TO CONTINUE IN
THIS GAL IS FULLY IMPLEMENTED IN
ALL OF ITS BASES.
THERE'S A GREAT VULNERABILITY
THE STATE WITH THAT IN IBM IS IN
A POSITION TO THEN.
QUOTE ANY COSTS THAT THEY WANT
ANY PRICE TO US THAT THEY WANT --
TO LIMP ALONG THIS SYSTEM FOR US
INTO WE'RE IN A POSITION I HATE
TO BE SO CYNICAL BUT I EXPECT
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK YOU'RE THE
SAME THING NEXT YEAR.
MONTREAL ALL MOVED ITEM.
ONE IF YOU WANT.
WE HAVE -- ISSUE.
ONE THE MOST -- I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU'RE MOVING IN ITEM ONE
THE CS YES HAS WRITTEN
[inaudible] ONE THIS ITEM FIVE
YEARS.
I THOUGHT I HEARD YOU SAY ITEM.
ONE ISSUE ONE ISSUE.
ONE WHICH ISSUE ONE WHICH IS TO
APPROVE THE BUDGET AS WELL.
THIS IS THE INCLUDES A ONE POINT
THREE MILLION GENERAL FUND A
SPORTS SIX ADDITIONAL POSITIONS
[inaudible]
ALTERNATIVE PLAN.
I'M SORRY YES UNDER C. S. P. S..
RIGHT. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
ALL ON THE SAME SHEET OF MUSIC.
SO WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THAT
AS FAR AS IT RELATES TO THE
STATE PAYROLL SYSTEM -- IF IF WE
GO WITH BE -- RECOMMENDED
SOLUTION WHICH IS THE SIX
POSITIONS IN THE FUNDING ON THE
ON THE STATE PAYROLL SYSTEM.
WE WILL INCUR A ONE YEAR DELAY
ON THE CURRENT PROJECT
[inaudible]
AND IN A FINANCE.
IS IN SUPPORT OF THIS NEW
SCHEDULE DELAY CURRENTLY THIS
PROJECT AS YOU KNOW HAS THE
REPLACEMENT PROJECT FOR PAYROLL.
HAS BEEN ON TRACK AND IT'S IN
THE POWER OF PROCESS AND WE WILL
SEE D. T. APPROVAL.
BUT THE ALTERNATIVE ONE THAT'S
RECOMMENDED FOR SUPPORT THEIR
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS OUR SCHEDULE.
AND BY A FULL YEAR AND AND THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE SEES
THAT AS A NEGATIVE.
OKAY I'M CONFUSED WE MAYBE LOOK
AT DIFFERENT -- MATERIALS -- SO.
pANALYSIS ON ISSUE?
ONE SO IT IT SAYS.
LET ME READ THIS AND THAT.
THIS IS CORRECT.
IT SAYS S. ZERO REQUEST FUNDING
TO SUPPORT.
SIX SESSIONS IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY IN
ONGOING DO YOU WORK ON THE
PROJECT OF HIS WILL DRIVE THE
PROCESS OF ASSESSING OPTIONS.
AND DESIGNING A NEW STATE WIDE
THEY WILL APPROACH AND THAT
YOU'RE SAYING THAT THAT'S NOT
ACT.
WELL I AM SORRY THAT IS ACCURATE
THAT THAT LANGUAGE IS ACCURATE
AND THAT IS -- THE APPROVED BCP
BETWEEN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND THE SCO.
BUT WE DO HAVE A CONCERN WITH
THAT APPROACH.
WE HAD A SECOND ALTERNATIVE IN
THE B. C. P..
WHERE WE REQUESTED -- TO STAY ON
TRACK WITH THE CURRENT SCHEDULE.
THIS APPROVED ALTERNATIVE DELAYS
THE CURRENT PROJECT BY TWELVE
MONTHS OR MORE.
AND WE WERE SEEKING TO AVOID ANY
FURTHER DELAYS ON THE STATE
PAYROLL SYSTEM.
BECAUSE IT'S SUCH A VULNERABLE
AND FRAGILE SYSTEM YOU'RE ASKING
BOTH KNOW THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
ADVOCATE THAT WE BOTH KNOW.
ONE CORRECT.
AND THAT.
CHRIS MALE AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE PAYROLL
SYSTEM PROJECT.
NOT ONLY DOES ALTERNATIVE ONE
DELAY THE PROJECT PLANNING BY AB.
I DON'T SEE WHAT WHAT WHAT IS
ALL MAYBE.
AFTER IS WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
ALTERNATIVE ONE AND ALL SO TO
LET ME MAKE A SUGGESTION BECAUSE
THIS IS ALL.
FIRST OF ALL WE JUST HEARD ABOUT
THIS A FEW MINUTES BEFORE.
YOU KNOW THE MEETING STARTED SO.
IT'S REALLY UNFAIR.
TO DISORDER DROP THESE.
PROPOSED CHANGES OR OBJECTIONS
SO I WOULD -- SUGGEST THAT WE
HOLD THIS OPEN SO WE COULD SORT
THIS OUT -- BECAUSE IT IT CAN BE
VERY CONFUSING TO US TO HAVE
THIS OUT WITHOUT THE NOTICE IN
THE INFORMATION ON THE
CONVERSATION.
THAT WE NEED SO -- I DISLIKE THE
HOLDEN -- PULLED IT OPEN.
THE BUDGET ARE BOTH SO WHEN YOU
BRING IT BACK.
MAKE SURE WORKERS [inaudible]
THAT'S FINE -- ARE NOW THEN --
REST OF THE BOAT ONLY.
OKAY SO THE THE BOAT ONLY.
I'M GONNA LIST THE VOTE ONLY --
ITEMS. TWO THREE AND FOUR SEVEN
NINE AND 1-113-141-8220
[inaudible] FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY TO THIRTY FIVE OKAY.
SO THAT SOME OF THE BOAT ONLY
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO THERE'S THREE OF PARTS TO THE
VOTE ONLY.
THAT'S THE FIRST PART.
OKAY SO.
LIKE I HAVE A MOTION
[inaudible]
WE JUST [inaudible]
PUBLIC.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY ONE OF
THOSE ISSUES.
OKAY HEARING NONE SEVERAL MOTION.
I MOVED.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
TURNED AROUND THE CENTER NOTHING
HI THERE I'M BURKE [inaudible]
OKAY.
THEN WE'LL HAVE THE THE NEXT
THREE OR VOTE ONLY ARE
[inaudible] TWENTY SIX TWENTY
NINE AND THIRTY SIX PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ANY ONE OF THOSE
ISSUES [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THE MOTION [inaudible]
WE'LL CALL.
RATHER RIGHT.
THERE NIELSEN ABSTAINED.
NUMBER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY THE NEXT SET IS OUR ISSUES
NUMBER [inaudible] 681-215-1617
[inaudible] TWENTY FIVE AND
TWENTY SEVEN IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ANY ONE OF THOSE
ISSUES.
HEARING NONE COULD HAVE A MOTION.
SANTA ROSA I HEAR NOTHING NO.
CENTER I'M BURKE.
OKAY IN ADDITION TO ALL THAT WE
ARE PULLING ITEM.
FORTY TWO ON THE AGENDA TODAY.
THIS IS A NICE AND EASY
[inaudible]
SO NOW.
GOING. TO TO OKAY. TWO THIRTY
SEVEN OKAY ISSUE.
THIRTY SEVEN THERE WE GO
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
WHICH I WHICH ITEM WERE YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
ITEM [inaudible]
SEVENTEEN OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
FOR YOUR ACCOMMODATIONS AFTER
BAKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE DID WANT
TO NOTE THAT WE HAVE PREVIOUSLY
TAKEN A SUPPORT ON THE
GOVERNOR'S ME REVISION.
TO IN ALL FUNDS THE CASTERS TO
HELP DISTRICTS WITH ADDITIONAL
AT SUPPORT FOR THEIR EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE WE ARE.
WE DO NOT AGREE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE ALLEY --
REGARDING THIS ITEM -- I DID
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE APPRECIATE
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDS THAT THE
SENATE IS PROPOSING TO HELP
DISTRICTS WITH EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTIONS WITH CASTERS.
WE HAVE NOT HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DIGEST THIS INFORMATION BUT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO COMMUNICATING
WITH YOU ON THE ADDITIONAL FUNDS
AND APPRECIATE.
THAT THE SENATE WANTS TO WORK TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL EMPLOYER
RELIEF TO SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY --
ISSUE [inaudible]
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING I'M JIMMY HEREIN
FRANCHISE TALKED BOARD.
I'M ITEM THIRTY SEVEN IS
RESOURCES BEEN REQUESTED SO AS
TO BE CAN IMPLEMENT THE MANDATE
PENALTY AND STUFF CITY PROPOSALS
RELATED TO HEALTH INSURANCE.
IT IS ASKING FOR VARIOUS
RESOURCES BEGINNING IN NINETEEN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AS THE PROGRAM IN OF TV'S
COMPLAINS THAT.
REALLY MATURE.
AND TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TO BE
IS OFTEN TOLD THE SHINS TO BEGIN
IMPLEMENTING THE TECHNOLOGY
NEEDED TO SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM.
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS OF
TO BE REQUEST RESOURCES FOR
RETURN PROCESSING INVALIDATION.
CUSTOMER ASSISTANCE I AM IN A
FORCE MY COLLECTION ACTIVITY AND
TO GUARD AGAINST INAPPROPRIATE
PAYMENTS.
MY MILLION TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE OF TO BE WILL REDUCE
POSITION AUTHORITY FOR RESOURCES
FOR TECHNOLOGY STOCKS.
THAT HAVE COMPLETED A ONE TIME
WORK AND BUILDING THE VARIOUS
SYSTEMS.
THESE RESOURCES ARE CRITICAL TO
ENSURE F. TO BE COULD AND
MINISTER THESE PROVISIONS AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE [inaudible]
AND WEBER. FOR IN WEATHERFORD
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE -- WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
WITH THE PROPOSED APPROACH TO
ADMINISTRATION -- WE DON'T KNOW
IF YOU HAD QUESTIONS ABOUT OTHER
ASPECTS OF THE PROPOSAL -- WE WE
DO NOT.
WE'VE REVIEWED THE ASSUMPTIONS
BEHIND THE REVENUE PROJECTIONS.
FOR THE THE PENALTY REVENUES AND
IF THEY'RE REASONABLE.
ALTHOUGH WE WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
IF THEY WILL BE IN CERTAIN.
GOING FORWARD -- FOR THE PLAN TO
BUILD THE SUBSIDY.
ANALYST FIRM TO FINANCE THESE
ARE NECESSARY SOURCES FOR
ADMINISTERING THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE.
AND HELPING -- EXPAND THE
SUBSIDIES FOR HEALTH CARE
PREMIUM [inaudible]
SANDERS.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
RECOMMENDATION TO IMPROVE AS
BUDGET.
I HAVE A MOTION.
SILVERADO HI THERE NIELSEN.
THERE ARE BURKE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
-- ITEM OR
ISSUE THIRTY EIGHT DEPARTMENT OF
TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION
[inaudible]
MORNING.
WELCOME MICHELLE KILL STICKER
WHEN YOU DEPARTMENT TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION TODAY.
SENDING ON THE SITE.
OKAY THIS IS AN ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSAL SO OF MAY RE REVISED OF
OF PROPOSES TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WOULD PROVIDE AN
EXEMPTION.
THEMSELVES USE TAX FOR SALES OF
DIAPERS MITCHELL PRODUCTS.
CALIFORNIA GENERALLY TAXES A
SALEABLE TANGIBLE PERSONAL
PROPERTY LESSONS THERE IS A
SPECIFIC EXEMPTION.
OUR FROM SALES TAX.
IT IS ALSO GENERAL RULE FOR THE
SALES TAX TO ALLOW FOR
EXEMPTIONS FOR CERTAIN SAYS
CITIES.
THE PROPOSED APPROACH TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE RECOGNIZED THE
NECESSITY NATURE OF DIAPERS AND
MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS.
AND THIS PROVIDES AN EXEMPTION
FROM SALES TAX [inaudible] FOR
DIAPERS.
CHILDREN AND FOR MR.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IS TO MAKE CERTAIN THE
SUBSIDIES AFTER FAMILIES MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
PARTICULARLY FOR THE NEEDIEST
FAMILIES.
THE COST OF THESE EXEMPTIONS ARE
ESTIMATED AT SEVENTEEN AND A
HALF MILLION GENERAL FUND AND IN.
TWENTY NINE TWENTY AND THIRTY
FIVE MILLION IN A GENERAL FUND
IN NINETEEN I'M IN. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BOTH THE EXEMPTIONS
ARE SCHEDULED FOR SUNSET.
I'M SORRY YOUR THEIR SCHEDULED
TO TAKE EFFECT OF JANUARY ONE
TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY AND TO
SUNSET AT THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO ALLOW REVIEW AND
AND THIS CONFLICT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
LEO.
CHRISTINE WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND WE HAVE A
FEW COMMENTS ON THESE PROPOSALS
FIRST -- AS FINANCE MENTIONED --
CALIFORNIA SALES TAX HAS SIMILAR
EXEMPTIONS FOR CERTAIN
NECESSITIES.
HOWEVER AT THE SAME TIME THE
SALES TAX ALSO APPLIES TO A LONG
LIST OF SESAME IS -- OUR OTHER
COMMENTS MOST OF THEM ARE
SUMMARIZED HERE IN IN THE AGENDA
SO WE'RE GOING TO THEM AND IN A
A LOT OF DETAIL JUST.
BRIEFLY OUR FIRST ON THE DIAPER
EXEMPTION WE KNOW IT IT'S IT'S
LESS TARGETED BEEN SOME
ALTERNATIVES ONE ALTERNATIVE WE
IDENTIFIES TO USE THOSE FUNDS --
FOR CHILD -- SO THAT OUR SECOND
POINT IS A REGARDING THE EQUITY
CONCERNED AT THE MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS EXEMPTION IS ATTEMPTING
PRESS WE WOULD JUST ONE OUT THIS
CONCERN IT'S CROSSCUTTING ACROSS
A VARIETY OF PROGRAMS AND SO.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS A VARIETY OF
OPTIONS FOR ADDRESS.
CROSS THE PERSONAL INCOME TAX --
CAL GRANTS POWER TO BRAVE OTHER
PROGRAMS NOT WHEN THE SALES TAX.
OUR THIRD POINT IS REGARDING THE
NOT SUNSET DATE ADMINISTRATION
IS PROPOSED FOR THE EXEMPTIONS
WHICH IS TWO YEARS AFTER THEIR
IMPLEMENTED -- IN OUR VIEW
THAT'S TOO SHORT A TIME PERIOD
AND WE YOU A RANGE OF FORTY TEN
YEARS AS MORE REASONABLE.
AND FINALLY OUR THIS BLESSED
EMITS FOR THESE PROPOSALS ARE.
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OR NOTABLY
DIFFERENT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION I SHOULD SAY THE
ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATES THAT
ALL YEAR.
SEC. THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND AND SEVENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS OVER ON OUR
ESTIMATES ARE.
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND.
ONE MILLION [inaudible]
SENATORS [inaudible]
QUESTION.
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE.
HELLO DANIEL CANDLE KAISER ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION IS A NON TEACHING
THAT THERE IS PENDING
LEGISLATION.
OR THIS BODY WHICH MADE IT TO
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK BEFORE SEE
TERRY HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN
OPPOSED TO THIS LEGISLATION
WHICH WAS ALSO VETO BY GOVERNOR
BROWN.
AS PROPOSED THESE EXEMPTIONS
WOULD REDUCE THE GENERAL FUND
REVENUES BY MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TO TWENTY
TWENTY AND THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS EACH YEAR THEREAFTER.
WITH A PROP NINETY EIGHT IMPACT
OF SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION AND
FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
RESPECTIVELY.
SEAT HERE A AS IT HAS IN THE
PAST -- JUST THE LEGISLATURE TO
FOREGO NON TARGETED TAX
EXEMPTIONS IN FAVOR DIRECT
FUNDING ALLOCATIONS.
THE BENEFIT THOSE MOST IN NEED.
THE REVISED PROPOSAL INCLUDES A
SUNSET OF TWO YEARS FOR EACH
ITEM RIGHTFULLY NOTING THE
STATE'S NEED TO PRIORITIZE
EXPENDITURES INTO THE FUTURE AND
IN THIS CASE OF POTENTIAL
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
THIS DIFFERS FROM FIVE YEAR
SUNSET AB PROPOSING ABIES. SIXTY
SIX AND A. B..
THIRTY ONE ADVOCATES OF PUBLICLY
CALLED FOR THE GOVERNOR TO
ELIMINATE THE SUN SO ALL
TOGETHER.
AND MARKS THE EXEMPTION
PERMANENT FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR LEVEL.
I'VE NEED SUCH AN ACTION WOULD
REQUIRE A TWO THIRDS VOTE OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO OVERTURN IN THE
FUTURE AND WE WOULD OPPOSE ANY
LENGTHENING OR TERMINATION OF
THE SUNSET.
IN THE FALL TWENTY EIGHTEEN SEE
TERRY COLLABORATED WTH THE
COALITION OF EDUCATORS AND
CHILDREN'S ADVOCATES TO CONDUCT
A PRETTY PRELIMINARY REVIEW OF
EXISTING TAX EXPENDITURES FROM
INCOME.
CORPORATION SALES AND USE TAX
[inaudible]
TAXES.
INDICATE THAT BY TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THERE WILL BE
A FIVE HUNDRED AND SIX POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR LOSS IN
REVENUE. TO THE STATE GENERAL
FUND SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TAX
EXEMPTIONS SUCH AS THESE DO NOT
TARGET THOSE MOST IN NEED
INSTEAD THEY SUBSIDIZE EVERYONE.
NO MATTER HOW WEALTHY OR POOR
THEY ARE AT THE EXPENSE OF FUNDS
THAT COULD OTHERWISE BE BETTER
USED TO ASSESS CALIFORNIANS WHO
NEED IT MOST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO JEFF NEAL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES.
M. WE CERTAINLY ARE SYMPATHETIC
TO THE REASONS FOR THESE TAX
EXEMPTIONS OTHER WE FEEL
COMPELLED TO POINT OUT THAT
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT LOCAL
IMPACT TO THE SALES TAX
EXEMPTIONS.
AS WELL IN FACT SLIGHTLY GREATER
THAN THAT STATE GENERAL FUND
IMPACT.
IN PARTICULAR ONE OF THE PIECES
OF THE THAT CLOSE TO LOCAL
AGENCIES COUNTIES IN PARTICULAR.
THE THE PART OF THE SALES TAX
RELATED TO TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT.
OR SHIFTED ABOUT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF PROGRAMS AND
FUNDING TO COUNTIES.
THE CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTION
THAT IN PROP THIRTY I WAS A
LINCHPIN OF OUR SUPPORT FOR THAT --
FOR THAT REALIGNMENT AND WE
BELIEVE THAT PROP THIRTY
OBLIGATES -- IT PROTECTS THAT
FUNDING OBLIGATES THE STATE TO
BACK BILL AT THE VERY LEAST THAT
PORTION OF THE SALES TAX
EXEMPTION SUCH AS SUCH AS THESE.
I'M IN TERMS OF THE OTHER LOCAL
IMPACTS FOR NINETEEN NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT AND THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICE PROGRAMS THAT THAT
PUNS ED THE PROGRAMS THAT SERVE
MANY OF THE SAME.
WOMEN AND CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
THAT THESE TAX CUTS WOULD
BENEFIT.
I AM.
AS WELL AS PROP ONE SEVENTY TWO
FOR LOCAL PUBLIC SAFETY AND OF
COURSE THE THE LOCAL FUNDING FOR
TRANSPORTATION AND AND BRADLEY
BURNS.
M..
WE WOULD NOTE THAT -- WHILE THE
STATE.
RIGHT NOW IN THESE HEARINGS IS
TRYING TO DECIDE HOW TO USE IT'S
A RECORD FUNDING LEVEL -- TO
BOTH FUND GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS AS
WELL AS PREPARE FOR THE
INEVITABLE A DOWNTURN THAT -- WE
WE KNOW WHAT'S COMING AT SOME
POINT IN THE FUTURE AT COUNTIES
ARE DOING THE SAME THING EXCEPT
THAT 75% OF COUNTY STILL HAVE
NOT RETURN. THREE RECESSION I
REVENUE LEVELS.
WHEN TAKEN IN REAL DOLLARS --
YOU KNOW PER RESIDENT SO -- WE
WOULD AT RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
THE THAT THE STATE CONSIDER BACK
FILLING THE LOCAL FUNDS THAT
WILL BE LOST DUE TO THESE
EXEMPTION.
THANK YOU.
I'M CHAIR MEMBERS JEAN HERS HERE
TAMMY HAVE THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA I AGREE WITH THE
COMMENTS OF OUR COLLEAGUE WE
WOULD URGE YOU TO CONSIDER THE
LOCAL IMPACT -- OF THE SALES TAX
EXEMPTIONS AGAIN NO PROBLEM WITH
ON THIS DATE.
RUGGED IF TO DECIDE HOW IT
SPENDS ITS OWN MONEY BUT THESE
DO HAVE CONSIDERABLE LOCAL
IMPACT.
ON ON LOCAL PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES AND WERE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING A BACK BILL UP FOR
THESE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
COMMENT YES [inaudible]
WELL.
IN ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE LAST.
TWO PRESENTERS.
I'M NOT ONE MUCH SYMPATHETIC. TO
TO SEE SACK COUNTIES ON THE
ISSUE OF REALIGNMENT.
I KNOW THAT THERE WAS A MAN I
MISS PRESSURE OVER THIS LONG
PERIOD OF TIME AND THE
COMPLICATIONS OF REALIGNMENT
[inaudible]
BUT COUNTIES.
BOUGHT INTO IT.
IT WOULD SEEM ALMOST
ENTHUSIASTIC.
AND SHOULD NEVER HAVE COUNTERED
THAT THE STATE WAS EVER GOING TO
PROVIDE.
FULL FUNDING IN ANY MANNER.
AND THE ADJUSTING MANNERS.
THE LONG TERM REALIGN.
WE ARE NOW IN OUR COUNTIES.
SUFFERING.
THIS IS A SMALL ITEM AND AND I'M
PREPARED TO SUPPORT THANK
[inaudible]
THE NUMBER.
SOME OF THE MOVE.
MOVIES SON TO APPROVE IS
BUDGETED.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
SENATOR RAZA HI THERE NIELSEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
FORTY IS IT.
OKAY WE'RE ON TO ISSUE THIRTY
NINE BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES
AND HOUSING AGENCY WELCOME.
THE MORNING GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU -- GOOD AFTER GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM TO ANY PARTY FOR
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL.
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
REQUEST NINE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
ONE THOUSAND GENERAL FUND AND
SIX POSITIONS IN FISCAL YEAR.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY AND
FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND FIVE
HUNDRED AND THREE THOUSAND AND
THREE POSITIONS ON GOING. TO
EXPAND THE HOMELESS COORDINATING
AND FINANCING COUNCIL. THREE OF
THE PROPOSED POSITIONS WOULD BE
LIMITED.
TERMS TO YOUR POSITIONS TO
CONTINUE IMPLEMENTING THE
HOMELESS EMERGENCY AID PROGRAM.
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET INCLUDED
THREE ONE YEAR LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS. TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT THE HEAP PROGRAM THAT
EXPIRED JUNE THIRTIETH.
NOW THAT THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND HE FUNDS
HAVE BEEN DISPERSED THE STAFF
NEEDS TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN MONITORING TO
ENSURE THESE FUNDS ARE USED
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY.
BY THE LARGE CITIES AND
CONTINUOUS OF CARE.
IN ADDITION TO THESE THREE
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS WE'RE
REQUESTING THREE PERMANENT STAFF
TO PROVIDE RESOURCES TO SUPPORT.
MINISTRY OF AN PROGRAM
ACTIVITIES OF THE COUNCIL.
IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT THIS
PROPOSAL DOES NOT INCLUDE
STAFFING AND SUPPORT FOR THE
PROPOSED NEW GRANT PROGRAM.
ON THESE COSTS WOULD BE COVERED
BY THE 5% STATE UP OPERATIONS
ALLOCATION I'M IN THAT PROPOSAL.
I'D BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE DETAILS
OR ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU THANK YOU -- LA -- PLEASE.
WHEN I LEFT LA -- THIS PROPOSAL
THINGS IN LINE WITH THE WORK
LOAD DEMANDS ON THE CAMP
[inaudible]
I KNOW [inaudible]
NOTHING THAT [inaudible]
MEMBERS -- INTER CHRISTIAN.
OUR MOTION PLEASE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
A LOCAL.
YOUR BROWSER HI NIELSEN.
NUMBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT ISSUE [inaudible]
FORTY OKAY.
ALL OF OUR FINANCE.
SO THE HOMELESS AID FOR PLANNING
SHELTERS PROGRAM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROVIDED FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION TO SUPPORT DEVELOPMENT
AND EXPANSION OF EMERGENCY
SHELTERS AND NAVIGATION SANDERS.
AND PROVIDE INCENTIVE GRANTS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR MEETING
MILESTONES -- WITH A
DISTRIBUTION METHODOLOGY BASED
ON A TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
POINT.
DISCOUNT -- THE MAYOR VISION
INCREASES THE ALLOCATION TO SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
REMOVE THE INCENTIVE GRANT AND
MEETING MILESTONE DISTRIBUTION
PROCESS -- UPDATES TO IT TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN POINT IN TIME
HOMES -- HOMELESSNESS COUNT AND
ADDS OF FLEXIBILITY TO THE USES
OF FUNDS.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
OKAY MEMBERS [inaudible]
QUESTIONS.
NO PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE.
I'M SORRY LA L..
SO THIS IS A REVISION ON THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY PROPOSAL --
OVERALL WE THINK THIS RECALLS A
MOVE IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION IN
PARTICULAR THE GENERAL RECALLS --
INCLUDED GENERAL PURPOSE FUND
THE TRIP DISINCENTIVE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND SO WE ARE PLEASED
TO SEE THAT THIS WILL ACTUALLY
GO TO DIRECT SERVICES TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
AMEN.
YES -- YOU ALREADY DID IT.
OKAY OF PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISIONS
PROPOSAL -- I ALSO WANTED TO
KNOW WE REALLY APPRECIATE
EVERYONE STAFF WORK ON BOTH THE
SENATE SIDE THE ASSEMBLY SIDE
THE ADMINISTRATION.
THIS FUNDING IS GREATLY NEEDED
AND APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU.
IN LOS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOU IF
I'M AND WE HAVE PROVIDED SOME
FEEDBACK DEMONSTRATION ON I'M
THEIR PROPOSALDISAPPOINTED TO
SEE THAT THERE IS NO SET ASIDE
CAR ABOUT.
FOR YOU SPECIFICALLY AS THE
SENATE HAS ADOPTED THEIR
FRAMEWORK AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONTINUE TO KEEP THAT -- WHEN
ENCOURAGE IT TO BE A 25% MATCH
AT A MINIMUM TO MERE WET THAT
PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE DEAD FOR
TRANSITION ANGIE'S AROUND 25%?
FOR TEH OR TO MATCH WITH THE
YOUTH REPRESENT OF YOUR POINT IN
TIME COUNTS WERE HEARING THAT
NUMBERS ARE ACTUALLY INCREASING.
IF WE DON'T ADDRESS YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THEY
WILL CONTINUE TO ADD TO THE
POPULATION I THINK WE CAN HAVE.
A MUCH MORE LONG TERM IMPACT IF
WE ADDRESS YOUTH CURRENTLY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
JOSH DUGGAR REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WE JUST WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S -- REVISED PROPOSAL
ON HOMELESSNESS -- SPECIFICALLY
WE SUPPORT THE INCREASE IN THE
FLEXIBILITY ON THE USE OF FUNDS
AND THE DIRECT ALLOCATION TO
COUNTIES AS WELL AS THE USE OF
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN POINT TIME
COUNTS.
WE DID JUST WANT TO REITERATE
THAT THE DIRECT ALLOCATION
COUNTIES BUT IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY JUST A LOT OF MONEY
FOR SITE LOAD COUNTY PROJECTS
THAT IT WILL BE USED.
FOR A COLLABORATIVE SYSTEM LEVEL
APPROACHES TO MEANINGFULLY
ADDRESS THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
IN THE COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WE
ARE A WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH KIM LOSES
COMMENTS WE HAVE ADVOCATED OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS. FOR THE
HOMELESSNESS COORDINATING
COUNCIL TO INCLUDE EDUCATION AND
WE WOULD URGE THAT OF FUNDING BE
ALLOTTED FOR THAT REASON LOS
ANGELES COUNTY HAS AN
OVERWHELMING NUMBER OF HOMELESS
YOUTH AND OF WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THOSE ISSUES ADDRESSED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
I MEMBERS JEAN HEARST HERE TODAY
AND WE HAVE THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA.
CONCUR WITH MY COLLEAGUE AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
REVISED PROPOSAL AND AGAIN THAT --
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF STUFF
WORK I IN THIS BUILDING THAT HAS
ASSISTED US TO GET TO THIS PLACE
WE APPRECIATE YOUR MOST POSITIVE
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
FROM.
OKAY.
THERE'S A FEW OF ITEMS HERE
THINK UNDER THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION -- WOULD IKE TO
ADOPT A SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE SENATE
HOUSING PACKAGE.
TAKE NO ACTION ON THE PROPOSED
HOMELESSNESS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE -- AND REJECT THE
PROPOSED LANGUAGE ON THE
CALTRANS -- SPACE WITHOUT
PREJUDICE.
OKAY WE HAVE A OKAY WITH THE
MOTION.
NUMBER MOTION FOR THE BOTH
[inaudible]
ROLL CALL.
YOUR BROWSER I NIELSEN.
NUMBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
FORTY ONE YOUR ISSUE FORTY ONE
PLEASE THE THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
[inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON BY THREE
MINUTES.
WELCOME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPTION IS BIG
FOR YOU.
TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY MY NAME
IS YOU HAVE TO CHAVEZ I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF FINANCE FOR
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS -- I'M
HERE WITH YOU TODAY DISCUSS OUR
RECENT INVESTMENTS IN EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS THROUGH THE THIRTY
MILLION.
FOR CALIFORNIA FARMERS FOR HIS
CAMPAIGN FUNDED BY AB.
SEVENTY TWO AS WELL AS TO
ADDRESS OUR REQUEST FOR THE ITEM
TODAY FOR ADMINISTRATIVE
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THE IN THIS
INVESTMENT.
SINCE AB SEVENTY TO ESTABLISH
THE ENTIRE THIRTY MILLION IN
LOCAL SYSTEM GRANT.
LOCAL ASSISTANCE FOR GRANTS
THERE WERE NO FUNDS ALLOCATED
FOR STAFF.
AND THE CALIFORNIA FARMERS
BRANCH CAMPAIGN WILL LEVERAGE
THIRTY MILLION THE BILL
RESILIENCY AMONG VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS IN UNDER RESOURCE
AREAS AT THE HIGHEST RISK FOR
DISASTERS. TWO SEVEN DIFFERENT
ARE OF PEAS REQUEST FOR
PROPOSALS CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS
WERE CONTRACTED BASED
ORGANIZATIONS.
WHO DIRECTLY IMPACT MERGING
FAIRNESS IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE
STATEWIDE OBJECTIVE TO ENGAGE AT
LEAST ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS?
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS TO THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH
REQUEST THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND A
HUNDRED ONE NINETY ONE THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SUPPORT IMPLEMENTATION. FOR
THIS CAMPAIGN.
THIS WILL PROVIDE ESSENTIAL
SUPPORT IN ADMINISTRATION OF THE
OVERALL CAMPAIGN FOR THE PERIOD
OF JUST. ONE AND HALF YEARS --
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS PLANTS
USES AUGMENTATION OF FUNDS TO
SUPPORT FOR TEMPORARY POSITIONS.
INCLUDING EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
COMMUNICATIONS MANAGER EMERGENCY
PRESS MEDIA SPECIALIST.
AB AND A DISASTER CERTAINLY
STIRS GRANT SPECIALIST ALONG
WITH THE CONTRACTS [inaudible]
THESE.
BY CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS FOR
SUFFICIENT STAFFING.
TO I AM HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON IN OUR
INVESTMENT ON THIRTY MILLION IN
A REQUEST FOR RECONSIDERATION
TODAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYTHING ELSE [inaudible]
LA YOU.
FINANCE NO PUBLIC COMMENT.
NOTHING MOBILE.
OKAY -- FOR VOCAL PLEASE.
BROWSER I NIELSEN.
NUMBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR GREAT WORK HE SAID
[inaudible]
SKIP [inaudible] TO SIX FORTY
FOUR OF FORTY THREE THIS IS THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
[inaudible]
GOVERNOR
.
OKAY.
GREAT GOOD AFTERNOON.
GET UNION MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DANNY CRUZ DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE UP WITH ITS COMMITMENT
TO ADDRESSING THE HOUSING CRISIS
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND MAY
REVISION PROPOSED TO SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION.
GENERAL FUND IN ONE TIME FUNDING
FOR PLANNING AND PRODUCTION
GRANTS. TO REGIONS AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO SPUR HOUSING
PRODUCTION -- TO HIGHLIHT THE
PRIMARY CHANGES IN THE MAY
REVISION.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSED
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR REGIONAL PLANNING TO
VISUAL ENTITIES AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO MEET.
NEW SHORT TERM HOUSING GOALS
THEY MAY VISION INSTEAD ALIGNS
THE SHORT TERM GOALS WITH THE
FORTHCOMING SIX CYCLE REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS ASSESSMENT.
AND ALSO MAKE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND COUNTY OFFICES OF ADMISSION
OF EDUCATION ELIGIBLE.
FOR THIS FUNDING -- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO PROPOSE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
INCENTIVE GRANTS TO
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE MADE
PROGRESS.
IN IMPLEMENTING THE PLAN AND
INCREASED HOUSING GOALS.
THE MAYOR VISION INSTEAD
INDICATES THIS FUNDING TO THE
INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH IS ADMINISTERED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. TO
PROVIDE CRAP FUNDING TO THE NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND REHABILITATION
OF INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SUPPORTS.
HIGH DENSITY AFFORDABLE AND
MIXED INCOME HOUSING AND WITH
THAT WILL HELP YOU TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
OKAY -- LA YOU.
HERE AGAIN WE THINK THE
REVISIONS TO THE GOVERNOR'S --
JANUARY HOUSING PLAN IS A MOVE
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AGAIN IN
PARTICULAR THE MOVE AWAY FROM
THE GENERAL PURPOSE INCENTIVE
FUNDS TO SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD.
COULD BE CERTAIN WOULD YOU YIELD
MORE CERTAIN BENEFITS IN ITS
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
SHORTAGE -- AND JUST SORT OF
GENERALLY -- THINK THAT TO THE
CONTINUED EFFORTS TO THINK ABOUT
LONG TERM PLANNING EFFORTS ARE
WORTHWHILE AND SO IN ENCOURAGE --
EFFORTS ALONG THOSE LINES IN THE
FUTURE AS WELL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OF MEMBERS ANY QUESTION.
NONE OF SHOULD PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE.
THE AFTERNOON -- VERY NICELY.
ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT TONY THURMOND --
THE SUPERINTENDENT SUPPORTS THE
INCLUSION OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION IN
THE ABILITY TO APPLY FOR THESE
PLANNING AND PRODUCTION GRANTS.
THERE ARE OVER A DOZEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS READY TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THESE THIS
ASSISTANCE FROM THE STATE SHOULD
PASS.
CALIFORNIA IS FACING A STATEWIDE
HOUSING AND TEACHER SHORTAGE WE
HAVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE THERE ARE TWO TO THREE
HUNDRED PICTURES SHORT THE YEAR.
BECAUSE TEACHERS CANNOT LIVE IN
THE COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY TEACH.
FUTURE CONSISTENCY STABILITY AND
EFFECTIVENESS IS DIRECTLY TIED
TO STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT.
AND THE NUMBER ONE REASON FOR
TEACHERS LEAVING THE STATE IS
LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WE APPRECIATE THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS RECOGNIZED THE IMPORTANCE OF
SCHOOL EMPLOYEE HOUSING AND WE
HOPE YOU WILL JOIN HIM IN
SUPPORTING OUR SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
AND TEACHERS.
AND ULTIMATELY OUR STUDENTS
REQUEST TO PRESERVE THIS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S NEWLY REVISED
PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I DO
WANNA -- ALSO COMMENT ON THE
CHANGE.
FROM THE GENERAL USE INCENTIVE.
OF FUNDS. TO ACTUALLY CONNECTED
TO TO HOUSING AND INFRASTRUCTURE
AND I THINK FOR ME PERSONALLY
THIS IS A GOOD EXAMPLE OF WHY
ARE PUBLIC COMMENTS AND
PARTICIPATION.
FROM ORGANIZATIONS IS SO
IMPORTANT BECAUSE SO MANY THINGS
ON HAPPEN ON THE GROUND THAT.
YOU KNOW EITHER.
HELP US COME UP WITH THE THE THE
RIGHT TO A BETTER DECISION
HOPEFULLY -- JUST BRING THINGS
TO LIGHT AND I WAS PARTICULARLY
IMPRESSED WITH THE COMMENT OF
ONE WITNESS WHO TALKED ABOUT THE
COULD USE THE MONEY FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
ALL CONNECTED TO TWO HOUSING
WHICH WOULD BE MUCH BETTER THAN
JUST A GENERAL USE.
SO -- I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
WHO COMES IN AND SPEAKS UP AND
SPEAKS OUT I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR OUR PROCESS HERE.
SO WITH THAT DO I HEAR A MOTION.
CAPTION OKAY THERE MIGHT.
OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
THIS [inaudible] THREE OKAY I
COULD.
WHICH IS NOT.
YET [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
WITH NEW.
IF YOU FORTY FOUR PLEASE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MEDICARE MEMBERS THING OF YOUR
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
THIS PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S STRATEGY TO%
ADDRESS THE STATE'S HOUSING
SHORTAGE AND AFFORDABILITY
PRESSURES THE GOVERNOR HAS
ISSUED EXECUTIVE ORDER IN
JANUARY TWENTY NINETEEN THAT
REQUIRES ECT TO WORK IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES.
TO DEVELOP AN INVENTORY OF STATE
OWNED PROPERTY THAT IS SUITABLE
FOR DEVELOPMENT OF FOR THE
HOUSING.
THE REQUEST FOR PROPOSALS
OFFERING LONG TERM LEASES TO
DEVELOPERS.
THE FIRST PROPOSED LEASES FOR
COMPLIANCE WITH EXECUTIVE ORDER
CRITERIA.
GOALS OF THE EXECUTIVE ORDER IS
A CAR COMPLETION.
ASSISTING STATE ON LAND FOR
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT WILL EXPLOIT
DEVELOPMENT AND FOR MY HOUSING
AND EIGHT UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES.
ADEQUATE FUNDING STAFFING AND
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTISE I
NEEDED TO EFFECTIVELY DEPLOY
THIS NEW HOUSING OPTION.
THE CITY IS REQUESTING A GENERAL
APPROPRIATION OF THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND I'M
GOING TO SEE OPERATIONS TO
IMPLEMENT THAT AVAILABLE
DEVELOPMENT OF FOR WHAT HOUSING
ON STATE OWNED LAND.
AND WITH THAT WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE LA YOU
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
OKAY CONNIE COMMONS MEMBERS.
THE END OF OF PUBLIC COMMENT
[inaudible]
OKAY -- THE RECOMMENDATIONS
APPROVED AS BUDGETED WHAT
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE.
A MOVIE.
CAN ROLL CALL PLEASE.
RAZA AYE NIELSEN SIDE NUMBER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY MOVE TO THE SHOE.
FORTY FIVE RIGHT TO THE PASSAGE
OF AB SEVENTY TWO IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE PROCESS. FOR
FORCING HOUSING ELEMENT LAW.
IN OTHER HOUSING RELATED LAWS.
WAS DEPENDENT ON THE RESOURCES
OF THIRD PARTY ORGANIZATIONS THE
CHALLENGE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ACTIONS IN THE COURTS.
NOW AB SEVENTY TWO ALLOWS EIGHTY
TO REVOKE IS FINDING THAT
JURISDICTION IS IN SUBSTANTIAL
COMPLIANCE WITH THIS PREVIOUSLY
PROOF HOUSING ELEMENT.
AND REFER THE NINE COMPLAINT
JURISDICTION TO THE GENERAL. FOR
LEGAL ACTION.
PLUS IT TO THESE NEW THIRTY TO
REFER CASES TO TRAIN GENERAL
WILL RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
WORKABLE FOR THE TRADE JOURNALS
AFTER THIS. EIGHTY DECREASES
REQUEST INCREASE IN ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
BUDGET AUTHORITY TO COMPENSATE
THE TRAIN GENERAL'S OFFICE FOR
COSTS INCURRED.
AS A RESULT OF THIS ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD.
AND WITH THAT ONCE OR ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
OKAY LA YOU.
COME FINANCE NON [inaudible]
MEMBERS [inaudible]
NO.
OKAY PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE.
OKAY HEARING NONE.
WE HAVE A RECOMMENDATION TO
APPROVE AS BUDGET IS.
I WOULD MAKE A RECORD.
MOTION THAT ON THE WELL IF YOU
WANT TO GET ON THE ROLE OF WOMEN
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
NUMBER THE TICKET THAT WE CAN
TAKE IT OR OKAY.
ALL RIGHT UP THANK YOU SO WE
HAVE A A MOTION LOCAL.
DRAWS A AYE NIELSEN NO NUMBER
WILL HOLD.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
ISSUE.
FORTY SIX DISASTER PREPAREDNESS
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY.
THIS PROPOSAL IS PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S LARGER DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS.
MONTH IN EVERY ME REVISION
PACKAGE WHICH INCLUDES RESOURCES
FOR VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS TO
ENHANCE THE FACES ASTERS BONDS
PREPAREDNESS AND SUPPORT THE
CONTINUITY THE STATE GOVERNMENT
DURING THESE DISASTERS.
IN THIS PROPOSAL THE C. REQUEST
TWO MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
BUDGET AUTHORITY FOR FOR
POSITIONS.
BUT THE FOLLOWING NINE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND TO STAB ISSUE
GRANTS MANAGEMENT SYSTEM.
THE HUNDRED AND TWO THOUSAND FOR
FOR POSITIONS FOR PERMANENT
DISASTER RESPONSE AND RECOVERY
UNIT.
IN. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
TO PERFORM A LOCAL NEEDS
ASSESSMENT AND DATA COMPILATION
RELATED TO THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CAMPAIGN WE'LL SEE WILD FIRES.
WITH THAT WILL ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
OKAY HELLO.
FINANCE NON MEMBERS.
NIELSEN QUESTION.
OKAY.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO APPROVE
AS BUDGETED.
AND THE MOTION [inaudible]
ROLL CALL.
THE RAZA I NIELSEN.
NUMBER [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ISSUE FORTY SEVEN IS A DILLON.
IS THAT.
DILLON WITH ONE OF THE WAS
DELETED
.
THE COUPLE.
MAKES REALLY GOOD POSTURE.
THE OPENING ON TWO ISSUES ISSUES
NOT FORTY FIVE ISSUE.
FORTY FIVE SENATOR.
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHAT IT WOULD?
AND THEN ISSUE FORTY FORTY SIX
IS THE PREPARE OUR ADMIN CHIEF
J. STURGIS -- I WANT TO BEGIN BY --
ASSURING SECRETARY SUSE REGRETS
FOR NOT BEING ABLE TO BE HERE IN
PERSON TO PRESENTTHE BUDGET
PROPOSAL -- I KNOW THAT SHE WAS
LOOKING FORWARD TO SHARING IT
WITH YOU -- BUT WILL PREVENT AT
PRESENT A BRIEF SKETCH -- TO
BEGIN A CENTRAL COMPONENT OF THE
PROPOSAL RELATES TO THE FUTURE
WORK COMP COMMISSION.
AND AS YOU KNOW ON MAY FIRST THE
GOVERNOR ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER ESTABLISHING THE FUTURE
FOR COMMISSION -- ITS TASK IS TO
A SIX TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
INFLUENCE AND PREPARE FOR
CHANGES IN OUR ECONOMY AND THE
NATURE OF WORK DUE TO
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION AND THE
AUTOMATION OF JOBS AND EXPANDED
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE -- THE
COMMISSION IS IS INTENDED TO BE
A PUBLIC PROCESS. ONE SS AN
AGENDA FOR ECONOMIC GROWTH IN
CALIFORNIA TO SUPPORT BOTH
INNOVATION.
SUSTAIN THE SOCIAL COMPACT.
A GUIDED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER -- THE
COMMISSION WILL TRANSLATE ITS
COMMITMENTS AND AGREEMENTS INTO
A SET OF RECOMMENDATIONS. FOR
THE GOVERNMENT PRIVATE SECTOR
AND LABOR.
A PROGRESS REPORT IS DUE TO THE
GOVERNOR IN FEBRUARY -- TWENTY
TWENTY BECAUSE OF THE WORK OF
THE COMMISSION IS ASSIGNED TO
LABOR AGENCY THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
INCLUDES A NUMBER OF POSITIONS.
TO ADD CAPACITY TO AGENCIES TO
FILL THE ROLE.
A SECOND AND RELATED FOCUS OF
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL IS HOW LABOR
AGENCIES FUNCTIONS AND
OPERATIONS ARE ORGANIZED TO BEST
RESPOND -- TO THESE CHANGES IN
OUR ECONOMY -- WE ARE TAKING A
FRESH LOOK AT HOW ARE
DEPARTMENTS WORK TOGETHER TO
SUPPORT ENFORCEMENT.
SERVICE DELIVERY AND OUTREACH BY
WAY OF EXAMPLE -- AGENCIES IN
THE MIDST OF RETHINKING HOW ITS
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES ARE ORGANIZED --
CURRENTLY THESE -- WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FUNCTIONS ARE HOUSED
IN FOUR DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS
WITHIN THE AGENCY WE BELIEVE WE
CAN BETTER ALIGN THESE PROGRAMS --
THROUGH A REORGANIZATION AND
CONSOLIDATION INTO ONE NEW
DEPARTMENT WITHIN THE AGENCY --
SO THE BUDGET PROPOSAL WOULD ADD
POSITIONS AT LABOR AGENCY TO
LEAVE THESE TYPES OF EFFORTS
WITH THE GOAL OF IMPROVING
SERVICES AND MAKING THE BEST USE.
THROUGHOUT THE AGENCY IN OUR
DEPARTMENT.
HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN ANY QUESTIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON JAZZ ALAMO WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE --
THE STAFF AGENDA INCLUDES A FEW
SEVERAL QUESTIONS REGARDING THIS
PROPOSAL -- ONE OF THEM RELATES
TO WHAT THE LEGISLATURE'S ROLE
WILL BE WHETHER BE OVERSIGHT OR
THE LEGISLATURE'S INVOLVEMENT IN
THE COMMISSION -- INCLUDING OUR
THE LEGISLATURE'S ROLE IN IN
DESIGNATING SOME OF THE BOARD
MEMBERS POTENTIALLY -- AND
THAT'S YET TO BE TO BE SEEN AT
THIS POINT A SECOND QUESTION
RELATES TO HOW THE WORK OF THE
COMMISSION WILL SORT.
BE INTEGRATED WITH THE UNIFIED
STATE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PLAN
THAT THAT THE STATE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD ASSEMBLES.
IT IS AN EXISTING PLANNED IT
MANY STAKEHOLDERS PROVIDE.
COMMENTARY AND AND FEEDBACK INTO
INTO HOW WILL THESE -- TWO PLANS
AND THE COMMISSION INTERACT OR
BE RELATED ON AND THEN THE THE
THIRD QUESTION THAT'S BROUGHT UP
THAT.
THAT WE ALSO WOULD -- SORT OF
ECHO IS THE HOW THIS COMMISSION
THE THE COMMISSION ON THE FUTURE
OF WORK WILL BE RELATED TO OR
SORT OF SUBSUMES THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE WORK
GROUP ON THE FUTURE OF WORK
WHICH WAS PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET.
THAT WORK GROUP HAD A A MORE
CLEAR CLIMATE POLICY FOCUS ON IT
WAS PROPOSED TO BE FUNDED WITH
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUNDS
AND IT'S SORT OF BEING
INCORPORATED AS WE UNDERSTAND IT
INTO THIS PROPOSAL SO THERE'S A
QUESTION AS TO HOW THOSE
ELEMENTS WILL BE.
WILL BE -- ACCOUNTED FOR WITH
THIS COMMISSION [inaudible]
MEN'S.
I AM MARK A MARK MEADOWS
APARTMENT A FINANCE JUST WANTED --
TO KNOW THAT WE HAVE NOT WE'VE
WE HAVEN'T HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO EVALUATE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS OF CUTS --
SUPPORTED AT THIS TIME.
OKAY MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
THIS BIG BY ITSELF.
THE THING.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
[inaudible]
SO.
IN TERMS THERE WERE A COUPLE OF
THINGS I'M NOT SURE THAT THEY'RE
LISTED THERE IS A A
RECOMMENDATION TO APPROVE BUT
CONTINGENT UPON.
CERTAIN SPECIFIC.
ITEMS -- AND I THINK THOSE ARE
ITEMS THAT ARE.
GOOD -- THAT ARE NOT YET
SPECIFIED -- THE ONLY ONE I
CAN'T SEE HERE IS WHAT YOU
MENTIONED ABOUT INTEGRATING WITH
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD.
THAT ITEM COULD BE INCLUDED IN
THIS LANGUAGE -- I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WHETHER INCLUDED
OR NOT WHAT WILL NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED AS A COMMISSION MOVES
FORWARD IT IT'S MORE OF AN OPEN
QUESTION OKAY.
OKAY.
MAIL TO MAKE SURE THAT SORT OF
NOTED.
BY YOU WITH SOMETHING.
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED SURE
MAKES I THINK IT'S A REALLY GOOD
POINT.
I CAN OFFER A LITTLE.
INFORMATION AROUND THAT -- SO
THAT WE OWE A STATE PLAN IS --
ESSENTIALLY A COMPLIANCE A
DOCUMENT ANNA THAT IS PART OF
THE WORKFORCE INNOVATION AND
OPPORTUNITY ACT ARE REQUIRED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR.
IN ORDER FOR THE STATE TO
RECEIVE ITS FEDERAL FUNDING IS A
FOUR YEAR STRATEGY -- FOR THE
INVESTMENT OF FEDERAL WORK FORCE
TRAINING AND EMPLOYMENT DOLLARS --
AND IT LAYS OUT HOW -- THE
VARIOUS -- CORE PROGRAMS THE
TITLE ONE THROUGH -- FOUR WILL
COORDINATE AND WORK TOGETHER FOR
SERVICE DELIVERY -- AND EVERY
TWO YEARS THERE ARE PLAN UPDATES --
THAT ARE SUBMITTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR SO IT WOULD --
THE THE WORK AND RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT COME OUT OF THAT THE
COMMISSION WOULD NATURALLY BE
KIND OF WOULD PERCOLATE INTO
THAT PROCESS -- BY EXTENSION AS
A BECAUSE OF THE WELL.
BECAUSE OF SEVERAL CONCURRENT
THINGS -- BECAUSE OF ALSO THIS
REORGANIZATION THAT -- IS
INTENDED OF WORKFORCE SERVICES
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT THEY'LL BE
MUCH GREATER ALIGNMENT -- ALONG
THOSE -- IN THOSE AREAS -- AND
THE COMMISSION WITH THE
COMMISSION'S ACTIVITIES BEING
PART OF LABOR AGENCY AS WELL SO.
WE SEE THAT AS KIND OF A NATURAL.
AFFINITY THERE [inaudible]
OKAY -- WITH QUESTIONS COMMENTS
[inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT [inaudible]
ON THIS.
OKAY HEARING NONE COULD HAVE A
MOTION TO APPROVE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
OF LOCAL PLEASE.
SENATOR ASA HI.
THERE NIELSEN.
CENTER I'M BURKE [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- PAID FAMILY LEAVE
ISSUE [inaudible]
FORTY EIGHT SENATE -- THE STAFF
AS WELL.
AND ALSO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRIOR SUPPORT OF OUR OTHER BY
GENRE.
FAMILIES -- THIS -- ITEM
INCLUDES SEVERAL DIFFERENT --
PROJECTS AT THE DEPARTMENT IS
WORKING ON ALSO INCLUDES THE
GOVERNOR'S DESIRE TO INCREASE IN
THIS RIGHT I KNOW WHO YOU ARE
MAYBE.
BUT POLITICS SENATOR -- DIRECTOR
PATRICK CUTTING WITH EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR A STAFF.
ESPECIALLY -- BUT I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO SAY THAT.
THIS GOES -- TO HELP THE PAID
FAMILY PROGRAM -- CONTINUE TO
THRIVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA VERY PROUD.
OF THE FIRST IN THE NATION OF
THIS TYPE OF A PROGRAM -- AND
THE ADJUSTMENTS THAT WE'RE
SEEKING HELP CONTINUED BUT
ACROSS [inaudible]
OKAY.
WHEN WE GET TO WHAT THE?
RECOMMENDATION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS HERE.
HELLO SORRY NO GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU -- ALL SERVE RESERVE
MY COMMENTS -- TO TWO COMPONENTS
OF OF THESE PROPOSALS THERE ARE
SEVERAL PROPOSALS GROUP TOGETHER
IN THIS ITEM ON ONE RELATES TO
THAT THE TECHNOLOGY PROCESS THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES TO
UNDERTAKE TO EXTEND PAID FAMILY
LEAVE FROM. SIX WEEKS TO EIGHT
WEEKS -- TYPICALLY -- TECHNOLOGY
PRODUCTS LIKE THIS -- ARE
OVERSEEN THROUGH THE THE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROJECT
APPROVAL LIFECYCLE PROCESS WHICH
IN NINETEEN OVERSIGHT PROCESS ON
THE TRAILER BILL. FOR FOR THIS
EXTENSION EXAMS THIS TECHNOLOGY
PROCESS PROJECT FROM THAT
OVERSIGHT PROJECT.
ON IT'S NOT CLEAR TO OUR OFFICE
AT THIS TIME WHY -- THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT IS BEING
EXEMPTED FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OWN OVERSIGHT
TOOL -- WHEN WHEN ASKING ASKING
THE DEPARTMENT THEY INDICATED TO
US THAT?
HOT THE PROJECT WAS THAT WAS
EXEMPTED FOR TWO REASONS FIRST
THAT IT'S RELATIVELY
STRAIGHTFORWARD IS NOT A
TERRIBLY COMPLEX ENDEAVOR --
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT AND
SO THEREFORE ISN'T AS RISKY AS
SOME OTHER PROJECTS.
AND SECONDLY THAT THAT --
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE
PROCESS CAN TEND A LENGTH.
IMPLEMENTATION ON THE BENEFIT
BEING THAT IT REDUCES SOME RISK --
BUT THE DEPARTMENT INDICATED TO
US THAT THEY WERE.
CONCERNED THAT BY GOING THROUGH
THE POWER PROCESS.
THEY MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THAT JULY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY IMPLEMENTATION DATE ON TO
REGARDING THAT THE TECHNOLOGY
PROCESS.
THERE ARE TRADE OFFS TO
DISCIPLINE THE FLAG IT FOR THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE AS IT CONSIDERS.
ITS OVERSIGHT ROLE AND AND AS
WELL AS THE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
OVERSIGHT ROLE OF OF THE
TECHNOLOGY PROCESS RELATED TO
PAID FAMILY LEAVE [inaudible]
ON MIKE MY SECOND SET OF
COMMENTS HAVE TO DO WITH THAT
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION IN
PARTICULAR -- OUTLINING -- SOME
OF THE DETAILS -- THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD WOULD LIKE TO
SEE AS AS PART OF A TASK FORCE
LOOKING AT IN INTO.
A PAID FAMILY LEAVE CHANGES IN
THE FUTURE.
OUR OFFICE EARLIER THIS YEAR.
RELEASE REPORT ON THE PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM AND ONE OF
OUR KEY RECOMMENDATIONS WAS.
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
ITS OWN GOALS AND AND POLICY
OBJECTIVES FOR PAID FAMILY LEAVE
WHICH MIGHT BE VERY SIMILAR TO
THE ADMINISTRATION'S OR THEY
COULD BE DIFFERENT -- AND IN SO
FAR AS THEY ARE DIFFERENT AND
THE LEGISLATURE'S INTEREST IN
PURSUING SOME THINKING THROUGH
GETS PRIORITIES FOR THE PAID
FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM -- THE TASK
FORCE AS PROPOSED IN THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE.
IN BODIES THAT ACTION AND
THEREFORE WE WOULD GENERALLY BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE LEGISLATURE
TAKING THOSE STEPS -- TO PURSUE
ITS.
OWN POLICY CONSIDERATIONS THE
PROGRAM.
DO YOU HAVE ANY.
RESPONSE TO THAT -- THINK THOUGH
IT WAS VERY THOUGHTFUL IN THEIR
OF RECOMMENDATIONS.
FINANCE HI A I'M AND AND JUST TO
SPEAK TO LA OF POINTS -- WE
PROVIDE IN AN EXEMPTION TO THE
SYSTEM ENHANCEMENTS RELATED TO
THE PFL EXPANSION -- MAINLY
BECAUSE YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S A LOW
COST -- IT'S A LOW COST PROJECT --
IT'S IT'S BEEN A REALLY LOW THE
LOW RISK -- THE DEPARTMENT HAS
EXPERIENCE -- A CREATING OR
IMPLEMENTING THESE TYPES OF
SYSTEM CHANGES AND AND AND TO
THE EARLIEST POINT.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM -- BUT THE
JULY FIRST TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY DEADLINE -- AND I WE DO
WANT.
TO ADD THAT WE ALSO HAVEN'T HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE THE
STAFF ARE RECOMMENDED --
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AS WE CANNOT SUPPORT AT
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
[inaudible]
OKAY.
DO YOU HAVE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THIS.
OKAY SO OUR RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PROVE THE BUDGET PROPOSAL.
ON AND OFF THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TONIGHT -- JUST ASK --
TRYING TO SEE WHERE I FIND IT
HERE -- WITH THIS.
WHERE WITH THE ISSUE OF -- WAGE
REPLACEMENT.
ON PAID FAMILY LEAVE WHEN AND
HOW WITH WILL THAT BE DEALT WITH.
IT'S THE ISSUE ITEM THAT I
BELIEVE THAT THE TASK FORCE WILL
EVENTUALLY TAKE UP -- AND IT'S
BEING CONSIDERED AS WE SPEAK IN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
OKAY SO THAT'S EXPLICITLY ON
THIS OKAY THANK YOU I COULD FIND.
ALRIGHT SO -- AGAIN OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO APPROVE HIS
BUDGET A PLACE HOLDER.
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE CAN I'VE
MOTION.
OKAY ROLL CALL PLEASE.
SENATOR ASA HI.
THERE NIELSEN ABSTAINED.
CENTER I'M BURKE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY EXTENSION IS BASED ON THE
FACT THAT THERE'S SOME CONCERN
ABOUT.
DEALING WITH THIS IN A TRAILER
BILL RATHER THAN A FULL HEARING
PROCESS IN THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THE CONCERN THAT.
AS WE WOULD EXTEND THESE KINDS
OF LEAVES WE'RE GOING TO PUT A
BURDEN ON THE BUDGET I'M AFRAID.
NOT MAYBE NOW BUT SOMEWHERE IN
THE FUTURE SO THAT'S MY
RESERVATION AND I HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
IS GOING TO SAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY WE MOVE ON TO ISSUE
[inaudible]
FORTY NINE HERE [inaudible]
CALPERS [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
OKAY GO HEAD RIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON JENNIFER HARRIS WITH
THE CALPERS FINANCIAL OFFICE.
AS THIS AGENDA ITEM ITEM NOTES
THIS IS BRINGING THE BUDGET BILL
LINE ITEMS IN LINE WITH THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY CALPERS
BUDGET AS APPROVED BY THE BOARD
OF ADMINISTRATION AS A SECOND
READING ON MAY FIFTEENTH.
TWENTY NINETEEN THE AMOUNTS
REPRESENT INCREASES IN OPERATING
EXPENSES FOR ADMINISTRATIVE AND
INVESTMENT OERATING COSTS AS
WELL AS FOR EXTERNAL INVESTMENT
MANAGEMENT AND THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR FEES [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
LA -- COMMENTS FINANCE NO
COMMENT MEMBERS.
YOUR CURRENT PUBLIC COMMENT.
I HAVE A QUESTION -- OF FOR
THESE AMOUNTS -- SAID MANAGEMENT
FEES.
INVESTMENT MANAGER BE SALARIES
AND BENEFITS IN OPERATING COSTS.
ARE THESE AMOUNTS.
OF HOW DO YOU REACH THAT WE HOW
HOW WHAT'S THE PROCESS OF
DECIDING.
EACH OF THOSE.
ARE THEY JUST AN AUTOMATIC FOR
EXAMPLE 2% NO MATTER WHAT.
WHAT GOES INTO DECIDING EACH OF
THESE ISSUES THAT ADD UP TO THE
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY SIX MILLION REFLECTS THE
FUNDS FOR WHICH CALPERS HAS
CONTINUOUS BUDGET AUTHORITY?
AND WITHIN THE CALPERS BUDGET WE
HAVE SIX EXPENDITURE CATEGORIES
AND SO WE HAVE A VERY ROBUST IN
OUT ANALYTICAL PROCESS TO
DEVELOP EACH OF THOSE.
WITHIN OUR ADMINISTRATIVE
OPERATIONS BUDGETS THAT SALARIES
WAGES AND BENEFITS AN AWFULLY
ANY COSTS FOR ALL THE BRANCHES
WITHIN CALPERS.
THE INCREASE IN THAT LINE ITEM
REFLECTS ANTICIPATED GENERAL
SALARY RETIREMENT INCREASES THAT
WILL BE MADE THROUGH THE STATE'S
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS
THIS NEXT UPCOMING YEAR.
AS WELL AS SOME INVESTMENT
CLASSIFICATIONS SALARY INCREASES
APPROVED BY THE BOARD OF
ADMINISTRATION.
IN FEBRUARY OF TWENTY NINETEEN
INVESTMENT OPERATING COSTS ARE
ALSO LOOKED AT ON A LINE BY LINE
BASIS THEY REFLECT THINGS FOR
SOFTWARE RELATED -- TO
INVESTMENT DATA ANALYTICS AND
THAT THOSE SORTS OF THINGS ARE
THEY ARE PROPOSED THROUGH THE
BUDGET OFFICE APPROVED THROUGH
THE EXECUTIVE TEAM AT CALPERS
AND THEN TO THE BOARD.
INVESTMENT EXTERNAL MANAGEMENT
FEES REPRESENT AMOUNTS THAT
CALPERS PAYS TO EXTERNAL PARTIES
WITH WHOM IT.
CONTRACTS TO MANAGE SPECIFIC
PORTFOLIOS THOSE AMOUNTS ARE
REALLY BASED ON WHERE WE THINK
MARKET CONDITIONS WILL BE NEXT
YEAR AND EXPECTED RETURNS.
IT'S REALLY A A PLACE HOLDER --
OBVIOUSLY WE WE DON'T HAVE A
CRYSTAL BALL WE DON'T KNOW --
WHERE OUR MARKET RETURNS WILL BE
BUT IF IF THEY ARE IN LINE WITH
SOME ANTICIPATED -- RETURNS AND
GROWTH AND THAT'S WHAT WE THINK
THEY WILL BE.
THE THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR
EXPENSES REPRESENT AMOUNTS THAT
WE HAVE WITHIN CONTRACTS FOR
THIRD PARTIES TO MANAGE OUR
HEALTH PROGRAMS -- OUR
SUPPLEMENTAL INCOME PROGRAMS AND
THAT CALIFORNIA EMPLOYER'S
RETIREMENT BENEFITS THAT BENEFIT
TRUST PROGRAM -- SO FOR THOSE
THERE ARE CONTRACTUAL AMOUNTS
BUILT INTO EACH CONTRACT -- BUT
THE REST IS AS WELL I'LL EXPLAIN
[inaudible]
OKAY.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
NO.
OKAY HEARING NONE CAME A MOTION
TO APPROVE IS BUDGETED.
SEVERAL CALL PLEASE SENATOR ALSO
BY SENATOR NELSON -- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- THIS IS ALSO FOR
YOU RIGHT SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE GO AHEAD.
GREAT SO AT THE END IT JANET DID
A REALLY GREAT JOB EXPLAINING
THIS ISSUE PROVIDING SOME
SOME OF THE IMPORTANT PIECES
SINCE NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE HEALTH --
CALPERS HAS BEEN THE STATE
SOCIAL SECURITY ADMINISTRATOR
WITH RESPONSIBILITY FOR
OVERSEEING CONTRACTS BETWEEN
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY THREE
PUBLIC WHERE STATEWIDE.
AND THE FEDERAL SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION -- BEFORE
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN CALPERS
WOULD ACTUALLY COLLECTED BOTH
THE EMPLOYEE AND EMPLOYER SHARE
OF SOCIAL SECURITY TAXES DEPOSIT
THAT INTO THE OLD AGE SURVIVORS
INSURANCE FUND.
AND THEN REMIT THE THE TAXES TO
THE IRS AND IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN THAT RESPONSIBILITY WAS
TAKEN FROM US AND GIVEN TO THE
IRS.
WHEN THOSE TAXES WERE SITTING IN
THE OLD AGE AND SURVIVORS
INSURANCE FUND THEY WERE EARNING
INTEREST AND THOSE INTEREST
AMOUNTS OR WHAT CALPERS HAS BEEN
YOU UTILIZING FOR THE LAST THREE
DECADES?
THE COVER ADMINISTRATIVE
EXPENSES ASSOCIATED WITH BEING
THE STATE SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATOR.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
THERE WILL BE INSUFFICIENT
RESERVES TO COVER ADMINISTRATIVE
EXPENSES.
PURSUANT TO EXISTING STATUTORY
AUTHORITY CALPERS CAN CHARGED
FEES AND ASSESSMENTS TO
EMPLOYERS TO COVER IT'S
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS.
STATURE REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO PROVE THE
METHODOLOGY BY WHICH WE ASSESS
THOSE FEES.
THIS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE --
BRINGS THE CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION OF THIRTY THAT WE
HAVE FOR THIS FUND ON BUDGET AND
IT ALSO CHANGES OF THE AMOUNT OF
PENALTIES AND ADDS INTEREST THAT
WE CAN CHARGE.
WORD WERE -- PROPOSING THIS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE BECAUSE AS YET WE'VE
NEVER CHARGED A FEE TO A PUBLIC
EMPLOYER TO DO THIS WE'VE HAD
ENOUGH FUNDS AND THAT RESIDUAL
INTEREST TO COVER -- THEREFORE-WE'RE NOT REALLY SURE HOW
SUCCESSFUL WILL BE IN COLLECTING
BECAUSE NEARLY TWO THIRDS OF THE
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED EMPLOYERS
DON'T HAVE CONTRACTS WITH
CALPERS THEIR NON CHALFORD
CALPERS COVERED EMPLOYERS -- AND
BECAUSE THE FEES ARE RELATIVELY
LOW THE PENALTIES WERE VERY LOW
AS WELL -- AND SO WE WANT TO
PROVIDE ENCOURAGEMENT TO
EMPLOYERS TO PAY IN A TIMELY
MANNER.
COMMENTARY QUESTIONS THE YEAR.
A PUBLIC COMMENT.
JUST ONE QUESTION ON THAT SINCE
THEY EMPLOYERS MANY OF THE
EMPLOYERS ARE NOT REQUIRED FOR
YOU TO HAVE A CONTRACTUAL
AGREEMENT TO ACTUALLY REQUIRE
THEM. TO PAY.
THESE INCREASED FEES -- I MEAN.
WHAT IS YOUR CALCULATION IS IT
THAT YOU EXPECTS A CERTAIN
NUMBER WILL PAY THE INCREASED
FEES AND THEREFORE THAT WILL
MAKE UP FOR THOSE WHO DON'T PAY?
NO WE WE WONDER HOW DO YOU.
MY APOLOGIES -- WE WE ARE
HOPEFUL THAT ALL WILL PAY -- BUT
AGAIN.
WE WE HAVE -- CONTRACTS FOR A
PENSION SERVICES ARE PENSION
BENEFITS WITH ROUGHLY EIGHT
HUNDRED OF THE EMPLOYERS ALL OF
THEM HAVE WHATARE CALLED
SECTION TWO EIGHTEEN CONTRACTS
BETWEEN THEMSELVES AND THE
SOCIAL SECURITY ADMINISTRATION.
SO WE HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH
THEM IN THAT WAY AND WE DO
MONITOR NO WHICH EMPLOYERS HAVE
CHOSEN TO PROVIDE SOCIAL
SECURITY BENEFITS TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES -- BUT TO THE FEE
STRUCTURE -- SETS THE RATES N
SUCH A WAY THAT WE ARE HOPEFUL
TO COLLECT FROM ALL ONE OF THE
BENEFITS OF BRINGING THIS ON
BUDGET AND WITH THE PURVIEW OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
THAT WE WILL ASSESS THE AMOUNT
OF RESERVES THAT ARE IN THE FUND.
AND IF WE FIND THAT THEIR
RESERVES ARE GETTING TOO HIGH
THEN WE WILL REDUCE THE FEE
STRUCTURE [inaudible]
OKAY.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE ANY WAY OF
REQUIRING ALL THE EMPLOYERS.
A PRACTICAL WAY.
NO I ASIDE FROM STATUTES SAYING
THAT CALPERS HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO CHARGE AN ASSESSMENT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT -- COULD HAVE A MOTION
TO APPROVE HIS PROPOSED.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
ROLL CALL CENTER DRAWS A HIGH
CENTER NIELSEN.
CENTER ON BURKE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RIGHT TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE --
FIFTY ONE BE THE LAST.
A CHANGE MY PHONE.
NUMBER IS THIS [inaudible]
YEAH NO [inaudible]
YEAH.
IF YOU DIDN'T TAKE SEVENTY SEVEN
YOGA SO DISABILITY HELLO MY IS
AND OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON.
OF WELL DONE.
AND THIS IS ON THE CENSUS OUT
FREE -- SO PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT JUSTIN
HOWARD WITH THE CALIFORNIA.
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY --
WITH ME IS THE DISCOGRAPHY THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA KLAY
COUNT TWENTY TWENTY OFFICE --
BEFORE YOU TODAY.
WE HAVE BROUGHT FORTH A PROPOSAL
THAT IS BUILDING OFF OF OUR
JANUARY TEMPLES ON WHICH WE ASK
FOR A FIFTY FOUR MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND WE TALKED ABOUT
THAT PROPOSAL IN OUR LAST
HEARING.
ON THE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU FOR
IT WITH AND AS PART OF A MAY
REVISE IS REQUESTING -- SEVERAL
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT WE THINK
ARE NECESSARY FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE A COMPLETE AND ACCURATE
A CENSUS COUNT -- TWENTY TWENTY
SPECIFICALLY WE ARE REQUESTING
TWO POINT NINE MILLION GENERAL
FUND AND OF THAT TWO POINT NINE
MILLION GENERAL FUND TWO MILLION
OF THAT IS SPECIFICALLY TARGETED
FOR NATIVE AMERICAN.
OUTREACH IS DIRECT OUT REACH TO
NATIVE AMERICAN -- TRIBE --
MEMBERS -- AND ORGANIZATIONS SO
PREVIOUSLY WE HAD PROVIDED --
FUNDING FOR NATIVE AMERICAN AT
POPULATIONS AND IN TWO MANNERS
ONE WAS DIRECT ALLOCATIONS TO
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT SO THAT THEY
CAN CONDUCT OUTREACH WITHIN
THEIR GEOGRAPHICAL SERVICE AREAS --
AS YOU AS YOU KNOW MANY OF THE
PEOPLE THAT LIVE ON TRIBAL LANDS
A NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT LIVE ON
TRIBAL LANDS IS ACTUALLY QUITE
SMALL FOR THE BULK OF THE
FUNDING THAT WE HAD PREVIOUSLY
PROVIDED WENT -- TO THE ATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS SO THEY CAN
CONDUCT THE OUT REACH TO THOSE
AT TRIBAL MEMBERS THAT DON'T
LIVE ON THE TRIBAL LANDS -- WHAT
WE'VE ALSO FOUND WAS IN HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR -- NATIVE
AMERICAN AB PARTNERS WAS THAT --
YOU KNOW THEY ARE VERY UNIQUE IN
NATURE THEY ARE SOVEREIGN
GOVERNMENTS -- AND THEY ALL
OPERATE A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY
THERE AND VERY -- HARD TO REACH
AREAS WITHIN THE STATE AND
PREVIOUSLY WE HAD EXPECTED MANY
OF OUR CONTRACTOR PARTNERS ARE
ADMINISTRATIVE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS COUNTY IS EXPECTED
TO TRY TO ENGAGE.
AND PROVIDE OUT REACH THROUGH
THE MONEY THROUGH THE FUNDING
THAT WE ARE PROVIDING THEM TO
THIS THIS VERY IMPORTANT PART
RELATION GROUP -- REALIZING THAT
THAT IS NOW JUST TOO DIFFICULT
TO DO GIVEN THE NATURE OF AND
THE UNIQUENESS OF ALL THE TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE OUT THERE THE
STATE IS NOW GOING TO DO THAT
DIRECTLY.
BY WORKING WITH THOSE SPECIFIC
ORGANIZATIONS THAT FOCUS IN THIS
AREA INSTEAD OF HAVING THIS
CONTRACTOR PARTNERS DO THAT.
SO THEREFORE INSTEAD OF
REDIRECTING THE RESOURCES THAT
WE'VE ALREADY AT ALLOCATED AND
PROMISED TO THOSE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND COUNTIES
WE ARE NOW ASKING FOR THIS TWO
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE THAT WE
CAN DO THAT DIRECT WORK AND WE
WILL WORK WITH THEM -- AND BY
PROVIDING A SPECIFIC -- MEDIA --
DEDICATED NATIVE AMERICAN
ORGANIZATION AS WELL AS THOSE
ADDITIONAL OUTREACH SERVICES THE
REMAINING PORTION OF THAT TWO
POINT NINE MILLION IS REALLY FOR
TWO THINGS ONE IS TO ALLOW THE
STATE TO ACQUIRE -- THAT
POLITICAL BATTLE EAKES -- TOOL
WHICH IS REALLY A CANVASSING
TOOL THAT ALLOWS US TO TRACK ON
HAD WHERE OUR PARTNERS ARE GOING
TO GO ON A DOOR TO DOOR BASIS
WHEN THEY START DOING THE NON
RESPONSE FOLLOW UP PERIOD --
WE'RE GOING TO ACQUIRE THAT TOOL
AND WE'RE GONNA MAKE IT
AVAILABLE TO ALL OF OUR
CONTRACTOR PARTNERS THAT WE WE
STANDARDIZE WHAT'S BEING USED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AS WELL AS STANDARDIZE THE DATA
THAT'S BEEN COLLECTED SO THAT WE
CAN UPLOAD IT INTO OUR STATEWIDE
OUT REACHING RAPID DEPLOYMENT
TOOL WHICH WILL THEN ALLOW US TO
ANALYZE HOW THINGS ARE GOING
INTO THE SPECIALLY AS WE GET ARE.
A REAL TIME DATA FROM THE US
CENSUS BUREAU AND TO THAT END
THE OTHER PIECE OF THAT IS A
POSSESS FUNDING SO THAT WE CAN
GET ONE ADDITIONAL POSITION TO
DO THAT BUNCH OF STATISTICAL.
DATA ANALYSIS ESTABLISH THOSE
METRICS AND SUCCESSES THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE LOOKING -- FOR RELATED
TO THE DATA SO THAT WE KNOW
WHERE TO TARGET OUR FUNDING COM
THAT CRITICAL PERIOD AS WE HOLD
BACK SOME OF THE FUNDS FOR
DEPLOYMENT DURING THE CRUCIAL
NON RESPONSE FOLLOW UP PERIOD.
ON AND FINALLY THERE ARE
ACTUALLY TWO LANGUAGE REQUEST
THAT WE'VE INCLUDED IN THIS
BUDGET -- ONE OF IS JUST OF MORE
OF A TECHNICAL -- LANGUAGE
RELATED TO THIS CLARIFYING THAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS THE AUTHORITY --
TO RECALL -- THE POINT ALL THE
POSITIONS THE CENSUS OFFICE --
AS EXAM POSITIONS THE OTHER ONE
A LITTLE BIT MORE IMPORTANT IS
IS REALLY BUDGET FLEXIBILITY
LANGUAGE SO WHAT WE FOUND -- AND
TALKING TO ALL OUR STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS OUT THERE WHO ARE
REQUESTING A SIGNIFICANT --
FUNDING TO BE AUGMENTED TO THE
CENSUS EFFORTS AS WE JUST DON'T
KNOW HOW MUCH FUNDING IS
ACTUALLY NEEDED AT THE END OF
THE DAY TO DO A COMPLETE AND
SUCCESSFUL COUNT I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY CAN ACTUALLY TELL YOU
THAT.
WE KNOW WE HAVE ENOUGH TO DO IN
REACH EVERYONE BUT THE THE BIG
QUESTION IS WHAT IS THE
FREQUENCY OF THAT OUT REACH THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE HOW MANY
IMPRESSIONS DO WE NEED TO DO TO
THOSE INDIVIDUAL.
HARD TO COUNT POPULATIONS AS IT.
TWO TIMES TEN TIMES A HUNDRED
TIMES NO ONE CAN ACTUALLY ANSWER
THAT QUESTION AND UNTIL OVER THE
SUMMER AS WE WORK ON OUR CATION
PLANS FOR ALL OF OUR
ORGANIZATIONS WERE PROVIDING
MONEY FOR WE CAN'T ACTUALLY TELL
YOU EXACTLY WHETHER OR NOT THERE
IS ANY GAPS IN ANY OF OUR
OUTREACH.
MEANING IS THERE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THAT ARE NEEDED FOR
LANGUAGE SERVICES IS THERE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THAT ARE
NEEDED FOR COMMUNITY EVENTS AS
OUR ADDITIONAL RESOURCES NEEDED
FOR THE NON RESPONSE FOLLOW UP
PERIOD.
THAT INFORMATION UNFORTUNATELY
WILL NOT BE KNOWN UNTIL WE GET
INTO THE LATTER HALF OF TWENTY
NINETEEN AND BECAUSE THAT
DOESN'T LINE UP WITH THE BUDGET
PROCESS FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
COME BACK AND ASK FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WE'RE LANGUAGE.
THAT ALLOWS US AND THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE TO AUGMENT
OUR BUDGET THROUGH THE JAIL BC
REQUEST -- SHOULD WE IDENTIFY
THOSE GAPS AFTER WE COMPLETE OUR
PLANNING PROCESS.
AND I GUESS I WAS REMISS ONE
LETTER LAST TECHNICAL THING
THAT'S INCLUDED AS ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY THAT'S REALLY RELATED
TO THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
POPULATION SAMPLE.
ENUMERATION THIS IS THE THE
BASICALLY A TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT
TO ALLOW US TO SPEND THE MONEY
THAT'S COMING TO US FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE CENSUS
OFFICES ACTUALLY.
CARRYING THE CONTRACT AS PART OF
THE FIFTY FOUR MILLION WE HAD
REQUESTED FOR MILLION FINANCES
EXISTING FUNDING OF A MILLION
DOLLARS THAT THEY ARE CHIPPING
AND FOR PART OF THIS -- PROGRAM
AND WE NEED THE ABILITY HAS BEEN
THAT FUNDING ONCE THEY SEND IT
OVER TO OUR OFFICE SO -- WITH
THAT AND AND THE DIRECTOR AND
ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE RELATED TO
THE CENSUS EFFORTS AT THE STATE.
THANK YOU.
LA -- FINANCE NOW.
MEMBERS SUMMIT PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WE
WANT TO THANK THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR TAKING THE STRIDES THAT THEY
HAVE TAKEN SO FAR FOR PROVIDING
EDUCATION FUNDING. FOR THE
EDUCATIONAL SECTORS IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WE PREVIOUSLY --
SUBMITTED A LETTER RECOMMENDING
ADD AN ADDITIONAL ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY EDUCATIONAL
SECTORS WHILE THE FUNDING THAT'S
BEEN PROVIDED OVER FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWENTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
TO THIS OF SECTOR WE KNOW THE
FACT THAT THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO REACH ALL OF THE SCHOOLS.
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY EIGHTY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE COUNTY
HALF OF THAT FUNDING WILL GO TO
LA U. S. D..
THE REST WILL GO TO THE OTHER
SEVENTY NINE SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS
THE STATE'S LARGEST REGIONAL
EDUCATION AGENCY FAMILIAR WITH
PROVIDING REGIONAL SERVICES TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY.
WE THINK IT'S A WISE INVESTMENT
TO PROVIDE FUNDING AT TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER SCHOOL
WITHIN TWENTY FIVE OF THE MOST
HARD TO COUNT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN THE COUNTY AND IN THE STATE.
AS WE KNOW SO WE THINK THAT
WOULD BE THE BEST USE OF
RESOURCES IN ADDITION.
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION HAS ALSO REQUESTED A
CERTAIN STAFF TO ALSO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
COUNTY OURSELVES WE ARE PREPARED
TO DO THAT WE KNOW HOW TO DO IT.
BUT WE TAKE THIS VERY SERIOUSLY
AS WE KNOW THE ADMINISTRATION
AND LEGISLATORS TO BECAUSE
YOU'RE HEARING THIS ITEM ONE OF
THE THINGS WE THINK IS MOST
IMPORTANT.
IS THAT WE KNOW IT CHILDREN COME
TO SCHOOL WITH THEIR PARENTS
THIS IS THE MOST REASONABLE
PLACE TO PUT RESOURCES AND WE'RE
PREPARED TO ASSIST WE LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR SUPPORT ON THAT
MATTER WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S REQUEST. FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING ON THE IN THE
FUTURE AS A TAKE ASSESSMENTS --
THROUGHOUT THE SUMMER AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
AND WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS -- MARTHA GUERRERO
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- FOR THE TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR A
LOS ANGELES COUNTY REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT -- DIRECT
ALLOCATION AND WE DID SUBMIT A
LETTER -- FOR REQUESTING FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS -- WE HEARD THAT --
THE ADMINISTRATION IS
CONSIDERING HOW YOU KNOW WE NEED
TO PREPARE FOR THE EXPENDITURE
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED -- SPECIFIC
EXPENDITURE AMOUNTS WE'VE HAD A
COMPREHENSIVE YOU KNOW OVER --
NOW TWO YEARS PROCESS TO DEVELOP
OUR SENSES OUT REACH AND EFFORTS
AND THE STATE HAS GIVEN US
ADDITIONAL -- REQUIREMENTS
DURING THAT TIME -- WHICH IS WHY
WE ARE ASKING FOR THE ADDITIONAL
TWO POINT FOUR MILLION -- WE HAD
WE ASK FOR TWO POINT SIX MILLION
LAST YEAR AND WE AND WE RECEIVED
A NINE POINT FOUR MILLION BUT
THIS YEAR WITH THE ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS I'M THAT THE STATE
HAS ASKED WE'VE IDENTIFIED THAT
WE NEEDED DDITIONAL TWO POINT
FOUR MILLION.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION SO THAT
WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
FUNDED -- TO COMPLETE THE
PROCESS THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS JULIE
SNYDER REPRESENTING HOUSING
CALIFORNIA AND THE CENSUS POLICY
ADVOCACY NETWORK FIRST WE WANT
TO EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION FOR
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION. TO
AUGMENT THE MAY REVISED BY
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND CBO'S AS WELL AS
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
FOR THE TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR CONTINGENCY FUND.
THE PENS ANALYSIS INDICATE THAT
THESE COMBINED ARE CLOSE TO THE
AMOUNT THAT WILL BE NECESSARY
FOR A ROBUST AND EFFECTIVE CBO
OUT REACH CAMPAIGN TO HARD TO
COUNT POPULATIONS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
BOTH HOUSES IN THE
ADMINISTRATION -- TO CRAFT
STANDARDS FOR DO F. TO APPLY --
WHEN DECIDING WHETHER TO SPEND
TO THE CONTINGENCY FUND -- AS
WELL WE WOULD LIKE TO EXPLORE
WITH YOU WHETHER IT'S POSSIBLE
FOR YOU THE LEGISLATURE TO
TRIGGER THE CONTINGENCY SPENDING
IF YOU FEEL IT'S NECESSARY WE
UNDERSTAND THERE MIGHT BE SOME
ISSUES TO WORK OUT THERE SO WE
REALLY APPRECIATE.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH YOU
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD
WORK YOUR STAFF HAS DONE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JOSEPH JETT OF ON BEHALF OF
CHAIR LET THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS -- ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS FROM
MY FROM MY COLLEAGUE THAT
PATIENT ALL THE WORK FROM THE
COMMITTEES THAT BUT THAT ALSO --
THE DEPARTMENT TO TO ENSURE THAT
THEIR SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES
GIVEN THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
UNKNOWNS OUT THERE AB AS OF THE
WE APPRECIATE THE NOT ONLY THE
TWENTY TWO MILLION BUT ALSO THAT
THE RECOMMENDATION FROM STAFF TO
INCREASE IT TO THIRTY MILLION.
FOR OUR REGION INDICATION FOR
CBS THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THE SUBPOENA ME DOES NOT KNOW
WHAT CHILDREN NOW WE'RE ALSO
MEMBERS SEE PAN WANTED TO THINK
THAT THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR
THE THE THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION --
AND THIS -- PROPOSAL ALLOCATION --
JUST WANTED TO REITERATE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S HOME TO NINE
MILLION CHILDREN OVER THREE
MILLION BETWEEN THE AGES OF ZERO
TO FIVE AND HOW WE NEED.
SPECIALLY TARGETED THOUGHTFUL
OUTREACH TO THOSE MIX THAT IS
FAMILIES TO LOW INCOME FAMILIES --
AND TO ENSURE THAT THIS BE HARD
TO COUNT COMMUNITIES ARE OUR
ATTIC.
ADEQUATELY COUNTED THANK YOU.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JENNIFER FEARING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NON PROFITS AND ALONG WITH OUR
TEN THOUSAND A MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE PART OF
OUR POLICY LINE'S WANNA A LINE
ARE REMARKS WITH THOSE OTHERS
FROM THE PAN.
AND THANK THE CHAIR AND STAFF --
AND THE ADMINISTRATION FOR ALL
OF THE EFFORTS WERE ALL ON THE
SAME PAGE AT KNOWING THAT HOW
MUCH THE CENSUS COUNT MATTERS
AND HOW CHALLENGING -- THIS THE
ENVIRONMENT IS AND CALIFORNIA'S
NONPROFITS AS HER FILLED WITH
TRUSTED MESSENGERS WHO ARE MORE
THAN PREPARED TO ENGAGE IN THIS
AND UNDER A SOURCING THEM WOULD
BE A MISTAKE SO WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CREATIVITY -- IN YOUR-SUPPORT FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR
CBO OUTRAGE THANK YOU.
NO I BOTTOM ALL REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
ON BEHALF OF OUR IMMIGRANT
MIGRANT FARM WORKER AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
WE STAND THE LINE WITH OUR
PARTNERS AT C. PAN WITH THE
COMMENTS THEY GAVE.
AND WE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
I JUST WANNA.
JUST AS A FINANCIAL COMMENT --
POINT OUT AN ARTICLE THAT SAID.
TWENTY FOUR CENSUS OFFICES ARE
BEING CUT IN CALIFORNIA -- SO I
THINK THAT SHOULD POINT TO HOW
WE HAVE TO MAKE UP -- FOR THE
LACK OF YOU KNOW FOCUS THAT THAT
THE STATE NEEDS AS FAR AS THE
CENSUS IS CONCERNED BUT I EIGHT
DO THINK.
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT.
TO WE'VE BEEN A NUMBER OF
HEARINGS AND MEETINGS ABOUT THE
SENSES -- I THINK HOPEFULLY
EVERYBODY BELIEVES THE SENSES IS
SO IMPORTANT THAT WE SHOULD MAKE
A MAJOR INVESTMENT -- BUT I DO
BELIEVE HAVING SPENT SO MANY
YEARS OF MY LIFE WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT THAT.
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO REGION
TO THESE HARD TO COUNT -- AREAS
AND NEIGHBORHOODS A WITHIN THE
LANGUAGE ACCESS THAT.
WE JUST DON'T HAVE AS THE AS THE
GOVERNMENT.
AS A FORMAL INSTITUTION DOES
EXIST OUT THERE I'VE SEEN IT ALL
FOR EXAMPLE IN COMMUNITIES OF
INDIGENOUS GROUPS FROM MEXICO
THERE ARE NEIGHBORHOODS THAT
NOBODY WOULD KNOW OTHERWISE AND
THEY SPEAK VERY SPECIFIC
DIALECTS BUT THERE ARE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT CAN REACH
THEM.
I'VE SEEN THAT.
SO I AM A BIG BELIEVER IN.
USING THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
OUT THERE THROUGH THE CBO'S I DO
AGREE -- WITH THE COMMENT FROM
THE EDUCATE AT OFFICE OF
EDUCATION THAT OUR SCHOOLS ARE
ON INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE MAY NOT HAVE SUPERMARKETS IN
EVERY NEIGHBORHOOD BUT WE HAVE A
SCHOOL IN EVERY NEIGHBORHOOD AND
PARENTS THERE GO TO THOSE
SCHOOLS.
SO I WOULD URGE ASSUMING WE CAN
GET THE RESOURCES THAT WE NEED
THAT.
THE EDGES OF OUR EDUCATION OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS PARTNER WITH C.
B. O.'S TO GET -- THE RESOURCES
THAT YOU NEED OUGHT TO BE ABLE
TO REACH EVERYBODY.
IN THIS SHOULD BE ON ALL OF US
IT SHOULD BE A NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY BECAUSE WE WON'T FACE
THIS PRIORITY FOR ANOTHER TEN
YEARS -- SO WITH ALL OF THAT --
THEM.
MEMBERS ANY COMMENTS
[inaudible]
ABOUT THIS [inaudible]
YES -- THIS IS THIS IS OBVIOUSLY
ONE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS THAT
WE'RE DOING HERE IN CALIFORNIA
OVER THE COURSE OF THE NEXT
TWELVE MONTHS OR SO.
AND IT SEEMS LIKE YOU'RE THE
RIGHT FOLKS TO LEAVE THE
OPERATION -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF THIS CATEGORY FOR COMING BY
MS JOHNSON FOR COMING BY MY
OFFICE YESTERDAY DISCUSS.
OF CERTAIN CONCERNS THAT I HAVE.
WE VIEW OUR JOBS JUST THROUGH
OUR LIMITEDEXPERIENCE IN THE
PRISM OF OUR EXPERIENCE WITH
WHATEVER TASK WE'RE DEALING WITH --
FOR US AN ORANGE COUNTY.
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAD A HORRIBLE
EXPERIENCE WITH CHERNOBYL
VENTURES AND AFTER OUR MEETING
YESTERDAY I REACHED OUT TO
OTHERS INCLUDING A LEGISLATORS
JUST TO SEE -- VENTURES IS THE
ORGANIZATION THIS PAST WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF DEVELOPING THE
PLAN AND REACHING OUT TO OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS IN ORANGE COUNTY
SO THAT WE CAN DO A COMPLETE JOB
OF OF COUNTING ALL THOSE THAT WE
POSSIBLY CAN -- FEEDBACK I'VE
GOTTEN NOT SURPRISINGLY IS THAT
THAT THEY ARE NON RESPONSIVE IN
RESISTANCE. TO PARTICIPATING.
AND SO -- AND I KNOW THAT
BECAUSE I I REACHED OUT AFTER
HEARING THESE COMMENTS FROM --
SEPARATE UP MYSELF I'VE NOT
HEARD BACK AFTER A PHONE CALL
AND EMAIL.
SO OBVIOUSLY THAT RAISES
CONCERNS ABOUT THE PROJECT ON
HIS FOCUS MY ATTENTION ON ORANGE
COUNTY.
AND SO I WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING HOW WE'RE GOING TO
REMEDIATE THAT WHETHER WE
TERMINATE YOUR OF VENTURES.
ON HOW WE CAN WHAT THE IMPACTS
WOULD BE THAT KIND OF THING.
BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
GIVEN HOW MUCH MONEY WE'RE
SPENDING ON THIS PROJECT AND HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS TO REALLY
DEVELOP.
ACCURATE METRICS TO KNOW WHETHER
OR NOT THIS MONEY IS BEING SPENT.
EFFICIENTLY EFFECTIVELY
[inaudible]
ACCOUNTABILITY IS IS TO HAVE
METRICS HARD TO DEVELOP METRICS
BECAUSE THIS IS A PROJECT WHERE.
THE ONLY METRIC IS WE'LL KNOW
NEXT APRIL OR MAY WHETHER OR NOT
WE'VE DONE A GOOD JOB.
IN THE INTERIM IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THAT THAT WE HAVE
ACCOUNTABLE AND I KNOW YOU I I'M
I'M PREACHING THE CHOIR BECAUSE
I KNOW YOU YOU KNOW ALL THIS BUT
BUT I AM CONCERNED BECAUSE MY
ONE BRIEF.
SORT OF OBSERVATION INTERACTION --
WITH OUR OWN ORGANIZATION.
WAS -- BOB.
WAS HORRIBLE SO -- I DON'T ONE
EXTRAPOLATE TO OTHER ACTIVITIES
IN THE STATE BUT I WOULD LIKE
IT'S SOME POINT TIME TO THE NEXT
YOU KNOW SEVERAL DAYS TO HEAR
WHAT WE CAN DO. TO DEAL WITH
THAT SITUATION.
WELL THANK YOU FOR THAT CENTER
AND THANK YOU FOR GIVING US THAT
FEEDBACK BECAUSE IT HADN'T MADE
IT UP TO ME -- UNTIL WE SPOKE --
JUST YESTERDAY AND I WANT
ENCOURAGE OTHERS THAT ARE IN THE
FIELD TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
GETTING THAT FEEDBACK BACK
BECAUSE YOU SHOULD BE ABLE. TO
GET THE RESPONSES THAT YOU NEED
IT WE ARE PRIDE OURSELVES ON A
TRANSPARENT.
AND INCLUSIVE PROCESS AND IF
FRANKLY IF YOUR OFFICE IS
INVOLVED AND YOU'RE RIGHT THERE
IN THAT AREA THAT DOESN'T BODE
WELL AS YOU SAY SO.
A WE'RE GOING TO BE GETTING
TOGETHER WITH OUR TEAM AND
OTHERS TO SAY YOU KNOW WHAT DO
WE NEED TO DO ANY TO ADDRESS
DOWN THERE -- BUT I WOULD SAY
THAT ON THE MEASURE BULLS AND I
THINK WE TALKED ABOUT THIS A
LITTLE BIT.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU DO IT LIKE
OUTRAGE THERE'S AN OUT REACH FOR
DIFFERENT THINGS WITH YOUR
GETTING THEM SIGN UP FOR HEALTH
INSURANCE ARE YOU GETTING THEM
TO VOTE. FOR CENSUS IS REALLY
SPECIFIC UP FOR ME AT LEAST AND
HOW TARGET NEEDS TO BE YOU CAN
DO ALL THE EVENTS THAT YOU HAVE
YOU CAN KNOCK ON DOORS.
BUT IF WE DON'T ALLOW ACCESS FOR
PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY FILL OUT THAT
FORM.
THEN WE LOSE WE ALL LOSE RIGHT
IT'S KIND OF LIKE YOU DO ALL
THIS VOTER OUR REACH BUT THE
NOBODY HAS A POLLING PLACE TO GO.
RIGHT SO WE E. AS A SORT OF A AT
THE STATE LEVEL AND AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL NEED TO BE REALLY
TARGETING AND UNDERSTANDING.
WHAT ARE WE DOING TO BUILD THOSE
AREAS WHETHER THEIR MOBILE
QUESTIONNAIRE ASSISTANCE CENTERS
I THINK -- SIR ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT.
WAS POINTED OUT WAS THAT THE US
CENSUS BUREAU IS NO LONGER GOING
TO HAVE QUESTION YOUR ASSISTANCE
CENTERS BRICKS AND MORTAR THAT'S
A HUGE YOU KNOW COMPARING TWO
THOUSAND TO A HUGE ISSUE.
SO THAT'S DEFINITELY AN AREA
THAT WE HAVE CONSIDERED AND WE
HAVE ASKED OUR CONTRACTORS
COUNTIES AND CBO'S WE'VE
INCLUDED IN THEIR MIND AT
HIGHLIGHTED IN BRIGHT YOU KNOW
READ.
BUT IF THEY'RE NOT CONSIDERING
THAT IF OUR CONTRACTORS ARE NOT
CONSIDERING THE VERY FACT THAT
YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE ACCESS.
THEN THAT'S A PROBLEM THEN --
YOU.
SAYING THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE
ADDING MORE AND MORE YOU KNOW --
REQUIREMENTS ON TO OUR
CONTRACTORS.
YOU KNOW WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
IT'S A SHARED RESPONSIBILITY --
AND IF OUR CULTURE TO SAY OH YOU
DIDN'T TELL US EXACTLY WHAT TO
DO AND SO NOW YOU KNOW WHERE I
CAN HAVE THE BE ABLE ABILITY
INDEPENDENT THAT CAN BE
PROBLEMATIC.
AND SO KNOWING THAT IF THERE'S
CONTRACTORS WE HAVE OUT THERE
THAT ARE LIKE.
NOT GETTING BACK TO AND BEING
TRANSPARENT WE NEED TO KNOW THAT
IF THERE'S CONTRACTORS ARE
SAYING WE DIDN'T ASK ME TO DO
THAT.
IT IS SPECIFICALLY DOWN TO THE
LETTER SO I'M NOT GOING TO IT
THAT'S A PROBLEM THAT WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THAT.
BECAUSE OF OUR YOU KNOW IF
EVERYONE IS ON BOARD WITH
GETTING EVERYONE COUNTED LEVEL
ON THE PEOPLE THAT WERE ACTUALLY
GIVING MONEY TO THAT WANT MORE
MONEY TO DO MORE THINGS.
WITHOUT YET TELLING US EXACTLY
WHAT THEY'RE GONNA DO I NEED TO
KNOW WHEN I NEED TO HAVE
CONFIDENCE.
THAT THESE CONTRACTORS ACTUALLY
KNOW WHERE THEY'RE HARD TO COUNT
OUR RATE AND THEY KNOW HOW TO
GET TO THEM SO I APPRECIATE THAT
FEEDBACK AND WE'RE GONNA GET
BACK TO A PARTICULAR ON THE
ISSUE THAT WE MET WITH YOU
YESTERDAY.
AND I ENCOURAGE YOU TO ENCOURAGE
ALL YOUR COLLEAGUES LET US KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE HEARING TO I MEAN
WE'RE WE GET FEEDBACK YOU KNOW
WE ONLY HAVE ABOUT TWELVE PEOPLE
ON THE GROUND.
ACROSS THE STATE ARE WE LOVE TO
HEAR THE EYES AND EARS BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO HAVE THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY -- BUT YOU GUYS
OUR EYES AND EARS AND SO ARE
YOUR STAFF SO WE ARE DEFINITELY
OPEN TO THAT.
WHAT?
AND THAT'S THE REASON REACHED
OUT TO OTHERS YESTERDAY.
IF THEY'RE NOT RESPONDING TO THE
CHAIR OF THE SENSES COMMITTEE --
IT NOT SURPRISINGLY THEY'RE NOT
REACHING OUT OR OR BEING
RESPONSIVE TO OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE COUNTY.
I DON'T WANT TO BE I'M A
BELIEVER THIS POINT BUT WHAT
WHAT I WANT TO DO IS I'M GONNA
VOTE BY ON THIS RECOMMENDATION
BUT I'M A ASK THAT THIS BE --
BASICALLY -- DOG THROUGH THE
PROCESS THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
AND SO FORTH BECAUSE AGAIN THIS
IS A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY
WE'RE SPENDING AND WE HAVE TO
HAVE ACCOUNTABLE IN TRANSPARENCY.
THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY SENATOR.
NOTHING MORE -- OKAY AND I I
WOULD ENCOURAGE JUST THEN -- TO
SUPPORT THIS -- I HEAR YOU
SAYING ABOUT YOU KNOW EXACTLY
SURE WHERE.
WHAT SOME OF THESE THINGS WILL
KNOWING START UNTIL YOU START
DOING THEM?
I'D RATHER YOU HAVE THE
RESOURCES.
OUGHT TO DO THIS AND NOT.
BE CUT SHORT WITHOUT THE
RESOURCES SO -- I I HAVE A LOT
OF TRUST AND FAITH IN A LOT OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT DO GOOD WORK
OUT THERE.
I WAS PART OF DOING A WORK
AROUND THE COVERED CALIFORNIA
THE FIRST TIME AROUND AND ALL
THE WORK THAT HAD TO BE DONE TO
DO OUT WE CAN.
TO YOU KNOW COMMUNITIES THAT
NEEDED THAT BUT OR HARD TO HARD
TO REACH -- I KNOW THERE'S WAYS.
AND HOW MANY I KNOW THIS A
FORMULAS ABOUT HOW MANY TIMES
YOU HAVE TO GO IT'S LIKE WHEN
YOU DO VOTER TURNOUT.
I KNOW IN CERTAIN COMMUNITIES
HOW MANY TIMES I HAVE TO GO TO
BE ABLE TO GET THOSE -- VOTERS
TO THE POLLS SO OF THIS MAY BE
EASE.
AND PARTIALLY UNIQUE BUT YOU
NEED TO HAVE ALL THE RESOURCES
YOU NEED TO HAVE THE FEEDBACK
YOU NEED TO HAVE THE HELP.
BECAUSE WE WANT TO GET INTO OUR
RURAL AREAS AS MUCH AS WE WANT
TO GET TO SOME NEIGHBORHOOD IN A
BIG CITY LIKE LA.
WE'VE GOT WE'VE GOT TO DO BOTH
SO WITH THAT -- THERE'S NO MORE.
PUBLIC WHERE WOULD HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT -- THE OF THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION -- APPROVE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL AND
AUGMENT OUT REACH CUP FOR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BY THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS.
OF WHICH TWO POINT FOUR IS
DEDICATED ALLY COUNTY AND ADOPT
THE TRAILER BILL PROPOSED.
I HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY -- ROLL CALL PLEASE SENATOR
ALSO BY SENATOR NELSON.
SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
END.
THAT DOES IT.
THANK YOU EVERYBODY THANK YOU TO
THE STAFF. FOR ALL YOUR HARD
WORK.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
HAVE A GOOD WEEKEND EVERYBODY'S
HAPPY DOESN'T MEAN DOLLAR